DEMO PART OF THE OF THE OF THE
DEMOUS AND IS A REALLY NICE
DEMOE SIDE THANK GOD.
A LOT GET ALL THE DEMOT YEARS I
DEMOK IT'S BEEN OPEN FOR ABOUT.
A DEMO.
BUT I DEMO THANK GOD EACH OF YOU
FOR DEMOG HERE TO TALK ABOUT
DEMO IMPORTANT TOPIC OF HATE.
I'M DEMOARD BLOOM THE ASSEMBLY
DEMOER OF FROM SANTA MONICA AND
I DEMOESENT THE FIFTIETH
DEMOMBLY DISTRICT AND TO MY IS
MY DEMOEAGUES SAID.
COM DEMOER GOV WE'LL HAVE SOME
DEMOODUCTORY REMARKS FOR YOU --
IN A FEW DEMONTS -- SAID NAY IS.
DEMO CULVER CITY RIGHT.
DEMOER CITY AND REPRESENTS THE
DEMOER.
DEMO OF THE THE FIFTY FIFTY
DEMOY FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
DEMOE'S AT THE OF US ITS GLOBAL
DEMO TO KEEP TRACK.
OF DEMO IS.
THE DEMOT INFORMATIONAL HEARING
DEMORE THE COMMITTEE ON THE
DEMOE HEY THE SELECT COMMITTEE
THE DEMOE OF HATE.
IT IS OUR DEMONTION TO HOLD THE
DEMOER OF HEARINGS OVER THE
DEMOSE OF A COUPLE OF YEARS
DEMON THIS.
I DEMO CHAIR OF SOUTHERN
DEMOFORNIA BUT IN VARIOUS PARTS
OF THE DEMOE BECAUSE IN FACT
DEMO IS AN ISSUE I'M SURE YOU
DEMO THAT IS AFFECTING.
DEMOYONE IN THE STATE OF
DEMOFORNIA EVERYONE OF OUR RE OF
THE DEMO OF OUR GREAT STATE.
AND DEMORE I GO FURTHER I WANT
DEMOK SANTA MONICA COLLEGE FOR
DEMOTING SO IN BEING OUR WHOLE.
DEMOINGS.
AND I DEMOA INTER.
A DEMO GOOD FRIEND AND SANTA
DEMOCA COP.
SD DEMOY GREENSTEIN TO SHARE A
FEW DEMOS NANCY.
YES DEMO NANCY A HAND.
DEMOK THE ACCORD -- V.. FOR THE
DEMOA MONICA COLLEGE COMMUNITY I
WON A DEMO MUSCLED WITH THE AND
THE DEMOLISTS TO OUR PERFORMING
DEMO CAMP.
AND AT SAM DEMO WE BELIEVE IN
THE DEMO.
DEMOSFORMERS.
OF DEMOATION AND THE FILM.
DEMOON ON THE OF THE POSSIBLE
DEMOS SECTION OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND WE DEMORVE THAT PUBLIC
DEMOCY STUDY. TO TREATED IN THE
DEMON SENIOR YEAR OF COLLEGE AND
DEMOUATE SCHOOL.
AND THE DEMOSIONS OF THE SEA
DEMORS AFFECT THE LIVES OF OUR
DEMOENTS THEIR FAMILY AND KEEP
DEMOE THREE DAY.
WE DEMOEVE THAT COMMUNITY
DEMOEGE STUDENTS WITH ONE TO
DEMON ABOUT THE ROLE WE CAN PLAY
DEMOECTIVELY AND INDIVIDUALLY.
IN DEMOING PUBLIC POWER THE SENT
TO OUR DEMOICIPANTS ARE A
DEMOCRACY.
IN TWO DEMOSAND AND TEN WE THE
DEMOIC CA INSTITUTE HERE WAS
DEMODED.
IN TWO DEMOSAND AND TWELVE WE
HAD OUR DEMOT GRADUATING CLASS
AND DEMOE THE ONLY -- COMMUNITY
DEMOEGE OFFERING A DEGREES IN
DEMOIC POLICY IN CALIFORNIA
DEMOEVES IN ACTION SO WE'RE VERY
DEMOD -- TO BE HERE TODAY AND TO
BE -- DEMO WITH BLOOM SO OFFICE
AND DEMONING THIS EVENT AND WE
DEMO WANNA I'M THANK YOU RICHARD
FOR DEMOERSHIP WHERE YOUR
DEMOTITUENTS.
AND WE DEMOECIATE ALL YOU DO FOR
THE DEMOEGE AND OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND DEMO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT
TO DEMOODUCE COUPLE PEOPLE IN
THE DEMOENCE.
DEMO ME IS ONE OF THE SANTA
DEMOCA CITY -- COUNCILMEMBERS ON
DEMO [INAUDIBLE]
DEMO RANGER.
WE DEMOECIATE YOU BEING HERE AND
DEMO THAT -- THIS EVENING.
DEMOED TO BE FOR FOR FOR ALL OF
US.
DEMOK YOU NANCY -- I'D ALSO LIKE
TO DEMORVE THAT -- YOUR DATE WE
DEMORVE YOUNG HAS WHAT THE THE
DEMOITT NUMBERS FOR THE
DEMOCAUST.
AND WE ARE DEMORED TO HAVE HERE
DEMOY A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR.
DEMOE FIRESTONE AND HER DAUGHTER
DEMOK.
NAY DEMOD YOU MIND STANDING.
DEMO.
DEMOE BALL IT WELL ACTUALLY BOTH
DEMOE AND CLUB OF VOLUNTEER.
DEMOLARLY FOR THE MUSIC OF THE
DEMOCAUST ANGELA -- SHE SPEAKS
TO OUR OF DEMOSES REGULAR BASED
IN IS DEMO THAT FOR YOU HERE'S
AND IT IS. ONE OF THE DEMO
DEMOCTIVE WAY.
AND DEMOLE OF A SINK I HATE IN
OUR DEMOETY TODAY SO THANK YOU
FOR DEMOG THAT FOR IT'S A
DEMOCATED.
DEMO OF HATE IS A AS THE I TOLD
A OF A DEMOG AS I THINK WEEK
DEMOER I'D HATE IS IN THE BIBLE --
DEMOTLY FRIENDS I'M ONE SLEW THE
DEMOR.
WE DEMOT IMAGINE THAT HATE WAS
DEMO OF THAT -- ROBBIE I MY WIFE
AND I DEMO IN BARCELONA RECENTLY.
WE DEMO.
A DEMORKING ABOUT THE HOW
DEMOREDS OF YEARS AGO ABOUT FIVE
DEMORED WELL ACTUALLY.
OF THE DEMOISH INQUISITION
DEMOENED AND THE JEWS WERE
DEMOLLED.
DEMO [INAUDIBLE]
DEMON HATRED.
AND SO -- DEMO IS NOT SOMETHING
DEMO IS NEW BUT IN RECENT YEARS
DEMOE BORNE WITNESS TO UP MORE.
AND DEMO FREQUENT ATTACKS BY
DEMOLDENED TO PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE DEMOD WHO ARE TARGETING
DEMOVIDUALS AND GROUPS OF
DEMOOUS RELIGIOUS AND ETHNIC
DEMOGROUNDS.
OF DEMONTLY THE MOSQUE ATTACKS
IN NEW DEMOAND OF EASTER CHURCH
DEMOCK IN SRI LANKA WHICH WAS
DEMO THREE WEEKS AGO AND HERE AT
DEMO WE WATCHED IN TWENTY
DEMONTEEN AS WHITE SUPREMACISTS
DEMO TORCHES MARCHED IN
DEMOLOTTESVILLE.
DEMOINIA WALL CHANTING -- JEWS
DEMO NOT REPLACE US.
IN DEMOTY SEVENTEEN A MAN SET
DEMO TO A MOSQUE IN TEXAS AND
DEMO LAST MONTH THREE
DEMOORICALLY BLACK CHURCHES WERE
SET DEMOZE IN A TWO WEEK TIME
DEMO IN LOUISIANA.
DEMOIER THIS WEEK UP TO ATTACK
THE DEMOA MONICA PIER AND
DEMOETS IN LONG BEACH --
DEMOLDED AGAIN A VERY BACKYARD
AND TO DEMOKFULLY WAS SUCCESSFUL
DEMOARDED BY -- VIGILANT FBI
DEMOTS.
IN THE DEMO SIX MONTHS WE
DEMOESSED THE TREE OF LIFE
DEMOGOGUE ATTACK IN PITTSBURGH
DEMOH PROVED TO BE THE LARGEST
DEMOORIST ATTACK ON JEWISH
DEMOICANS -- UP ON A SOIL AT
DEMOTLY SIX MONTHS.
THE PO A DEMOGOGUE JUST A FEW
DEMO AGO WAS SIMILARLY TARGETED.
AND IT WAS DEMOLY OF A BIT OF
DEMOISM AND A BIT OF BLACK THAT
DEMO A COMBINED -- SO THAT THERE
DEMO NOT MORE THAN THAT TRAGIC
ONE DEMOALTIES AND THOSE WHO
DEMO INJURED -- AT AT THE PO A
DEMOTING.
AND DEMORDING TO A NEW REPORT
DEMO WE'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THE
THE THE DEMO IS A REPORT THAT
THE DEMO DEFAMATION LEAGUE --
DEMOASED LAST WEEK JUST THIS
DEMO HATE CRIMES AGAINST JEWS
DEMO DOUBLED LAST YEAR IN
DEMOARISON TO THE TWENTY
DEMONTEEN NUMBERS.
IN DEMOTY SEVENTEEN THE SOUTHERN
DEMORTY LAW CENTER IDENTIFIED AT
DEMOT SEVENTY NINE ACTIVE HATE
DEMOPS IN THE STATE OF
DEMOFORNIA. TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS
DEMO UNFORTUNATELY A RECORD
DEMOING YEAR FOR US LOCAL AS
DEMOE WERE NEARLY THREE HUNDRED
DEMO CRIMES REPORT IN LOS
DEMOLES ALONE.
THE DEMOWHELMING MAJORITY GROUPS
DEMOESTRATED ATTACKS SUBSCRIBE
TO THE DEMOLS OF WHITE SUPREMACY
AND THE DEMO
DEMOE SINCE THE PRESIDENTIAL --
DEMOTION OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
DEMOFORNIA STATE WELL FOR ITS
DEMORSITY AND EQUAL RIGHTS
DEMOECTION LAWS.
DEMOICALLY IS HOPE MORE HATE
DEMOPS THAN ANY.
IN THE DEMOE THESE HATE GROUPS
DEMO IN AROUND THE LOS ANGELES
DEMO AND WHILE THESE GROUPS.
ARE DEMOL JUST AS A PERCENTAGE
OF THE DEMOALL POPULATION.
DEMO NOT INSIGNIFICANT DOES HAVE
DEMO.
I AM DEMO THAT THEY ARE BECOMING
DEMOEASINGLY SOPHISTICATED AN
DEMONIZED.
IN DEMO CASES THEY FORMED
DEMOANCES AND CREATE.
DEMOELLA POSSESSIONS.
DEMO'VE CHANGED THEIR PARENTS TO
SEE DEMO PROFESSIONAL AND WE DID
THE DEMONIZATIONS WITH ADOPTED
DEMOS.
A TO A DEMO ACADEMIC.
IN AN DEMORT TO CHANGE THE
DEMOTICAL LANDSCAPE CREATED
DEMOTICAL PARTIES TO ELECT LOCAL
DEMOE AND NATIONAL CANDIDATES.
AND DEMO CLEAR THAT THEIR
DEMOION IS TO AND TRADE THEM IN
ST.
AND DEMOCK AMERICA HOW IT IS.
SO HOW DO WE DEMO DOWN. FOR
DEMON HOW DO WE VIEW THE
DEMOINGLY GROWING LEVEL OF
DEMORDS OTHER GROUP.
HOW CAN WE DEMOOTS?
DEMOH WITH SENTIR HATE SPEECH ON
DEMOAL MEDIA.
AS DEMOERS AND ARGUE HOW DO WE
DEMOARE COMMUNITIES.
BE DEMO TO HANDLE [INAUDIBLE]
DEMORAL CONFRONTATION.
IS DEMONDED TO BE A PERCENT.
AS FOR DEMOCS TO GUIDE US
DEMORDS FINDING ANSWERS TO THE
DEMOTIONS. TO DATE WE HAVE EXTRA
DEMOENT.
DEMOR A NUMBER OF TOPICS THAT
ARE DEMOINED IN THE AT THE AND
DEMO THEY ARE DONE WITH THEIR
DEMOENTATIONS WILL HAVE A PERIOD
OF DEMO FOR PUBLIC.
DEMOFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO HEAR
DEMO ALL OF YOU WHO WOULD LIKE
TO UP -- DEMO US COMMENTS BUT WE
DEMO TO DO IN.
YOU CAN DEMO OUT A PUBLIC
DEMOKERS THE CARD. FOR YOU CAN
DEMOIT A WRITTEN CONTENT.
OF DEMO WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
DEMO OF AFTER THE MEETING.
OF IS IF YOU DEMO TO WRITE YOUR
DEMOENT DOWN AT THIS THE INTO US
AND THE DEMO.
IS IF DEMOD LIKE TO TO THE PHONE
AND DEMO A LOOK.
AT THE WHO DEMO BE FROM THE
DEMOK.
I DEMO -- TO CALL OUT MELISSA.
DEMOE YOUR HAND ALYSSA
DEMOUDIBLE]
SO -- AM I DEMOENED MANY MANY
DEMOS ORGAN.
DEMOK YOU FOR THE APPLAUSE YOU.
DEMOE I WAS GOING WITH THAT?
DEMO OF BY STAFF ME HERE OTHER
AT BY DEMOF MAYBE HERE INSIDE
AND DEMO OF THEM ARE SOUGHT
DEMOUDIBLE] TO SEE. TO BE OF
DEMONG.
DEMON TO GRAB THEM FROM ME
DEMOODICALLY.
AND THE A DEMOSE FEEL FREE TO
DEMOIT THOSE.
WE DEMO
TO DEMOENT AT THE AT THE
DEMOENTATIONS ALL CALL NAMES
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMOOPHONE.
DEMO ME BACK THE COUNCIL DAYS
DEMO SEEM JUST LIKE ALL TOP. TO
DO -- ASK DEMO ALL.
THE DEMOTIONS UNTIL THE END OF
AND I DEMO ANOTHER MOMENT NOW --
FOR OUR FOR DEMOENTER.
DEMO JOANNA MENDELSSOHN WITH THE
DEMO DEFAMATION LEAGUE WHO IS
DEMO FOR I THINK IT'S YOUR THIRD
DEMOTH THIRD.
DEMOD PRISON [INAUDIBLE]
DEMOK [INAUDIBLE]
DEMOHALL WONG.
DEMORA COUNTY ELECTIONS MISSION
DEMOANDER DID KOWALSKI WITH THE
LOS DEMOLES POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND DEMOD WITH LOYOLA MARYMOUNT
DEMOERSITY AND WE'RE VERY
DEMOUNATE TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY
DEMOK YOU FOR TAKING TIME OUT
FOR DEMO SCHEDULES WHEN YOU
DEMOD BE RELAXING ON A THURSDAY
DEMOING.
AND DEMOG HERE [INAUDIBLE]
A DEMOMA.
GET DEMO SO.
I DEMOK YOU.
DEMOLY I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
DEMOEY.
DEMOH.
DEMOK YOU FOR BEING TODAY.
OF DEMO PARTICIPATION HEARING IS.
TO THE DEMOO DESCRIPTION.
AND THE IF YOU DEMO ANY OF THIS.
FOR THE DEMOTATION TO PURCHASE
IT ON THE DEMOCT COMMITTEE YOU
DEMO EACH MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
HAS AN DEMORTUNITY.
ASK THE DEMOKER.
DEMOCT COMMITTEE -- AND THEY CAN
DEMO DECIDE WHO SITS ON IT -- I
AM DEMORED AND HOW MANY
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMO
DEMO ASKED ME TO SIT ON THE
DEMOCT COMMITTEE ON AS ONE OF
DEMO MEMBERS AND GRATEFUL THAT
DEMO
DEMO ASKED TO CHECK BECAUSE I
DEMOK IT'S A VERY.
AND IT IS I AM DEMOABLY GOING TO
BE A DEMOES OF UNCOMFORTABLE
DEMOERSATIONS THAT WE SHOULD BE
DEMOARED TO CONTINUE TO HAVE.
I'M AND DEMOK YOU ALL FOR COMING
OUT DEMOGHT TO BE CALLED IN THIS
DEMOOUT YOU KNOW ON MONDAY ON
THE DEMOMBLY FLOOR.
DEMO NUYS A HOLOCAUST
DEMOMBRANCE DAY. EIGHT IT.
IS DEMOED I'M SOME COMMENTS ON
THE DEMOCAUST AND MAKE THAT WE
DO NOT GET OUR DEMO -- AND IT'S
DEMORTANT TO NOTE THAT THIS
DEMOTRY THE VERY ROCKY HISTORY --
AS DEMO TO EMIT INS AS IT
DEMOTES. TO OTHER -- AS IT
DEMOTES.
TO DEMOAL.
I'M IN.
DEMOTEEN TWENTY FOUR PASSED.
AN ACT ON DEMOH WAS REALLY.
A DEMO PIECE OF LEGISLATION
DEMOND EUGENICS.
AND HOW WE DEMOUDE -- IMMIGRANTS
AND DEMOLE WHO DID NOT LOOK
DEMOIC.
UP DEMO PARTICIPATING IN OUR
DEMOETY -- IT.
DEMOCE THAT WERE EXCLUDED --
DEMOS.
AND DEMO WAS REALLY ABOUT
DEMOECTING [INAUDIBLE]
MR DEMO.
AND DEMO'S UNFORTUNATE IS THAT
DEMO IS OFTEN NEW AGAIN.
SO YOU DEMO NOW WE'RE LISTENING
TO DEMONNA AND AND PEOPLE ARE
DEMOING OFF OF HER AND DEEP SO I
DEMO YOU KNOW OLDER PADS COME IN
DEMOE -- BUT UNFORTUNATELY SO
HAS DEMO.
DEMO YOU SEE -- SLAUGHTERED IN
DEMOR HOMES OF WORSHIP WHEN YOU
SEE DEMOCAN AMERICANS BEING
DEMOED THROUGH SO MANY OF OUR
DEMOETAL SYSTEMS WHEN YOU SEE
DEMOIAL AMERICAN MEXICAN.
DEMOICANS BEING DENIED ASYLUM.
DEMO SHOULD TELL YOU THAT HATE.
AND DEMOONALISM AND WHITE
DEMOEMACY IS ALIVE AND WELL.
WE DEMO AN OBLIGATION TO
DEMORONT THAT REALLY ABOUT WHAT
A DEMORSE DEMOCRACY LOOK LIKE.
DEMOUSE ULTIMATELY THAT IS WHAT
WE S. DEMO WAS AS AN IDEAL.
I'M NOW DEMO CRIME.
ARE DEMOIFIC.
DEMO SAY IN SEVEN HUNDRED ORDER
OF A DEMOION A YEAR.
DEMO INTERESTED IN WHAT -- THE
DEMO WILL -- DEAL TO US.
DEMO MORE INTERESTED IN HEARING
DEMO YOU ALL ABOUT HOW WE CAN
DEMO BACK THAT.
DEMOE IS A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DEMO SPEECH AND HATE SPEECH.
DEMOR PRINCE BETWEEN DISAGREEING
DEMO SOMEONE WANTING TO
DEMOHILATE THEM.
I'M AND WE DEMO TO MOVE PAST
DEMO.
DEMOUSE ULTIMATELY WE ARE
DEMOHING OUR YOUNG -- THIS IS
HOW YOU DEMO WITH OTHER.
YOU DEMO.
AND DEMORE PROBABLY REMINDING
OUR DEMOS.
DEMO WE HAVE FORGOTTEN THE PAIN.
DEMO THEY BOND THROUGH.
IN THE DEMODES THEY TRIED TO
DEMO TO GET US TO A MORE DIVERSE
DEMOUSIVE DEMOCRACY AND COUNTRY --
WE DEMOM TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
DEMOUCTIVE STATES IN THE COUNTRY
BUT AS YOU DEMOAL THE NUMBER IS
WE DEMO A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
AND AS WE DEMOINUE TO DEAL WITH
DEMOES AROUND POVERTY BUT
DEMOITY.
AND DEMOLATION GROWTH.
THE NEW DEMO IS IN ALL OF THE
DEMOES IS HATE.
DEMO TAKING SOMETHING BACK.
DEMO SOMEONE STOLE FROM ME.
AND DEMO CAN BE A VERY SLIPPERY
DEMOE.
DEMO A VERY DARK SPOT.
DEMO DEPRIVES US.
DEMOER THAN ALLOWS US TO WORK
DEMOTHER TO RISE THE TIDE FOR
ALL OF THE DEMO.
SO I DEMO TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
DEMOWING ME TO PARTICIPATE IN TO
DEMO -- FROM THE PANELISTS AND
DEMOMATELY TO HEAR FROM OUR
DEMOENCE SO THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR THE DEMOTATION.
DEMOK YOU.
DEMOE GOING TO BE AND THAT NOW
DEMO -- JOANNA MENDELSON OF THE
DEMO DEFAMATION LEAGUE AND TWO
AND DEMO BE GIVING US AN
DEMOVIEW OF THE STATE'S DEFACED
DEMO ON A NATIONAL LEVEL OF
DEMORE WE START THINKING ABOUT
IT A DEMOLE MORE CLOSER TO HOME.
DEMOG.
TO DEMOK YOU SO MUCH CAN YA HEAR
ME DEMO.
DEMO EXCELLENT THANK YOU GET FOR
THE DEMORTUNITY TO BE HER
DEMOMBLY MEMBER BLOOM WE
DEMOECIATE THE INVITATION TO
DEMOTY OUT.
I SO IT HAS DEMO THREE YEARS
DEMO I FOR NEEDED IN THIS FORUM.
AND AND DEMOGS SADLY WITHOUT
DEMOG TOO HYPERBOLIC HAVE NEVER
DEMO SOLD.
DEMO BEEN DOING THIS FOR
DEMOONALLY FOR CLOSE TO TWENTY
DEMOS.
AND FOR YOU DEMO AT A AS SOMEONE
DEMOLY C. ARE ROOTED IN TRACKING
DEMO.
THE DEMOSCAPE IS PRETTY
DEMOICULT TO LOOK AT ON ANY
DEMOING A FORMULA.
WE ARE WE DEMO THE LARGEST
DEMOST SKINHEAD POPULATION IN
THE DEMOTRY BASED -- IN SOUTHERN
DEMOFORNIA.
AS DEMOMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
DEMOIONED WE HAVE THE LARGEST
DEMOER OF HE GROUPS IN OPERATION
BUT DEMO DOESN'T EVEN COUNT.
DEMOE WHO ARE AFFILIATED AND
DEMO'S A MAJORITY OF THOSE THAT
WE DEMO IN OUR BACKYARD.
SO DEMO I WOULD LIKE TO DO WITH
YOU DEMOFLY IS TO KIND OF GO
DEMOUGH THAT SOMEONE OF A
DEMOSCAPE OF HATE.
THE DEMOS TO BE A LITTLE BIT
DEMO MITES PRIMACY BECAUSE THAT
IS THE DEMOT IN HIS VOICE THAT
WE ARE DEMO IN LOUDEST -- THESE
DEMO ESPECIALLY HERE IN OUR
DEMOYARD -- AND YOU LOOK NO
DEMOHER AS TO WHAT OCCURRED THIS
DEMO WEEKEND TO UNDERSTAND.
THE DEMOATS THAT WE'RE FACING AS
A DEMOON.
SO DEMOEMISTS ARE BECOMING MORE
DEMOED ENDS.
AND WE SEE DEMO EMBOLDENED.
DEMOTENCE MANIFESTED IN.
YOU DEMO HISTORICALLY THEY WOULD
DEMO KLAN ROBES AND SHIELD THEIR
DEMOS BUT NOW THAT RHETORIC THAT
HE DEMOE IS AIRING ITSELF IN
DEMO A PUBLIC WAY.
THE THE DEMORNET HAS SIR TO A
MAP A DEMO THAT BOY HAS BEEN
DEMOVIDUAL THE ABOUT THE KEEPING
A DEMO ON A GLOBAL LEVEL.
AND DEMOE SEEING THAT YOU AND
DEMOONIZE.
THE DEMORNET IN ORDER TO CARRY
OUT DEMOR BELIEFS AND IDEOLOGY
IN DEMO TO EVEN SEE.
DEMOERS AND YOU EVEN SEE -- A
DEMO WHETHER OR NOT IT'S FRIENDS
IN DEMOENCE IN THE CHRISTCHURCH
DEMOTING OR POWER AWAY THIS PAST
DEMOEND.
DEMOE THE PLOTS ARE DESIGNED?
FOR DEMONE THE PLOTS ARE
DEMOGNED TO BE MAGNIFIED TO A
DEMOAL LEVEL AND TO BE SPREAD
DEMOUGHOUT AND COPY CAT IT AND
DEMOORED AND POSTED FOR ALL
DEMOS OF DIFFERENT FORMS.
SO DEMOTY HOURS TRACKING A WHOLE
DEMO EXTREMIST GROUPS ACROSS THE
CAN IN DEMOG.
DEMOPS THAT ARE THE DEMOCRATIC
DEMOESS I CALL THIS THE JEOPARDY
DEMOD OF HATE ESSENTIALLY
DEMOUSE THERE IS THERE IS SO
DEMO GROUPS AND MOVEMENTS
DEMOVIDUAL NINETY JEEZ WE ARE
DEMOKING.
IF YOU DEMOD CHECK THIS PAST
DEMOEND THERE ARE OURS SEEMS TO
DEMOK.
DEMOMARKS RIVER UNTIL THE END.
THE THE DEMOOUS ATTACK THAT TOOK
DEMOE.
IN DEMO.
I DEMO A BREAK SLASH.
AND DEMO WEEKEND HAD BY THE
DEMOTE [INAUDIBLE]
I IF YOU GET THE DEMOFEST.
MY T. DEMOLE EYES BROWN I'M SURE --
DEMO ONE OF A MAN'S MIND AND WE
DEMOT PROVIDE US WITH.
DEMO HAND PULSE WE GRABBED
DEMOES OF THAT THE ALLEGED
DEMOTER.
I'M ONE OF THE DEMOGS WAS THEIR
PAY DEMOT.
AND YOU CAN SEE THE DEMOS THE
DEMOR THE ANIMOSITY THE EUROPEAN
DEMO IS DOOMS.
DEMOY JEW IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
DEMOCULOUS PLANNED IT GENOCIDE
OF DEMOPEAN RACE.
DEMOY JEW PLAYS HIS PART TO
DEMOAVE RACE AROUND HIM.
DEMO CONSCIOUS LEE OR OTHER KIND?
TOP DEMOT HIS.
GEN FOR DEMO.
IN DEMOST CHURCH TO THE CHURCH
DEMOER OF SELL ME AT MÁS.
AND DEMO IS IT HE'S AND THAT IS
AND YOU CAN SEE THE DEMOS THAT
DEMO IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE
DEMOS YOU SEE THE BIGGER WAR.
THE DEMO.
IT DEMO IS -- ARE RELATED.
IF DEMORE IN RATE.
AND GOT DEMOED.
YOU DEMO SEE THE VERSION OF HIS
DEMOSTIAN BACKDROP [INAUDIBLE]
DEMO.
AND IT DEMO AND SO FORTH IS IT.
X. DEMOY AMBLED DIMMER ENOUGH
AND TWO OF THE DEMOEST AGREED
THE DEMOE.
MAR BY DEMO A GAL HAS.
DEMO HOW WERE FAIR KIND OF A
DEMO DOT ORG TREAT THE HOW WEIRD.
VIS A VIS DEMO SEMITIC ATTITUDES
AND DEMO
IS ARE AT THE DEMOTE.
DEMO I REMEMBER JUST CHANGED WE
DEMOBLISH.
DEMO THE BC.
DEMOLY ATTACK.
DEMOT JEWISH COMMUNITY IN CASE
HE OF AN DEMOUNT.
THE DEMOSBURGH SHOOTERS SHOOTING
DEMO CLAIMS ELEVEN LIVES.
IN DEMO THIS WAS THE THIRD
DEMOEST YEAR ON RECORD.
DEMOE NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE IT'S
DEMOTY.
DEMOTY AT SIGNIFICANT -- AND THE
AT THE DEMOT REVEALED THAT FIFTY
DEMO PEOPLE WERE VICTIMS OF THE
DEMO SEMITIC ASSAULTS.
IN TWO DEMOSAND AND EIGHTEEN SO
DEMOKING DOWN THOSE NUMBERS YOU
CAN SEE A DEMOK DOWN FROM
DEMO620-1720. EIGHTEEN FOR AT
SIX IN THE DEMORBS HERE'S
DEMOERS WERE 48% HIGH.
IF YOU DEMO JUST THE YEAR HIGHER
SAW THE DEMOERS WERE.
DEMO HI.
SO WE DEMONITELY SEE IN THAT
DEMOEASE IN THE MOST RECENT.
I DEMO THIS.
DEMOL DID NOT FARE WELL AS
DEMOETE THE REST OF THAT ARE
DEMOAPS NOT AS AN NOT AT LARGE
DEMO.
AN DEMORIENCED IT 28% INCREASE
IN DEMOAY.
DEMODENTS PRO RATED.
DEMO RUNS THE GAMUT COULD BE THE
DEMODING.
AS DEMOALISM.
ALL THE WAY UP TO DEMOTS.
LOW DEMOL AND DANCE INSTANCE THE
DEMORE PROBABLY FAMILIAR WITH
DEMOIN OUR SCHOOL BUS WITH AND
DEMO
IT I OUR DEMOENTS.
DEMO ITS SENATE HARBOR HIGH
DEMOOL A WEEK IS A GREAT KID
DEMO THERE IN NEWPORT BEACH
DEMOFORNIA.
AND DEMO MAKE US LOST.
DEMOPT PERHAPS.
I DEMOE.
A DEMOLE WEEKS BEFORE.
OR DEMO IT UP THE WHOLE COST.
AND DEMOD HIS UNCLE LASSEN THAT
DEMO.
US.
AND DEMOE IN IF.
OF NOT DEMO FROM THE MAINSTREAM
DEMOIFICALLY FROM THE MIST
DEMOION.
AND WE SEE DEMO THE PRESS SAYS
DEMOLY AMMAN.
AT DEMO CUTE.
IS AT DEMOE.
THE DEMOTEEN WORDS IS A TRUCK
FOR DEMO PROMISES.
DEMO FOR MY SECURITY SINCE
DEMOLE AND A FUTURE FOR WHITE
DEMO. FOR THE LIFE BLOOD LUST
DEMO'S IN OUR NEXT GENERATION.
DEMO BE USING THE SET A SET.
DEMOCIDE FUTURE IS AT STAKE.
DEMO'RE RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
DEMOR.
DEMOTENCE AS I THINK WE'LL BY
THE DEMO.
DEMOYTHING.
IS AT DEMOE THEY LOOK IMMIGRANT
DEMO
DEMO ROLL IT.
DEMO LOOK A DIVE TO THE AT ALL
DEMOGS THREATEN THEIR EXIST OF
DEMOSE THERE GALLAGHER.
THE DEMO TO AN EIGHTY EIGHT ON
THE CAN YOU PUT DEMO FOR SURE
LET ME GO DEMO -- H. IS IS LESS
OF DEMO EVENT.
SO. DEMOT STANDS FOR A I'LL HIT
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMORISE SAYS -- NOT SEE. ONE
TWO DEMO FIVE HIS GREEN IDEOLOGY
DEMOSPOSE IT TO TODAY.
AND DEMOER THEY BELIEVE DID A
DEMO JOB.
BUT HE DEMO'T FINISH THE JOB.
AND SO IT IS DEMO IMPERATIVE IN
THE IN THE DEMODROP OF YOUNG HOW
DEMOL.
AND THE DEMORSTANDING OF
DEMOCAUST REMEMBRANCE THIS PAST
DEMO.
DEMO WHITE SUPREMACISTS I JUST
DEMO WHAT WAS WAS ARTICULATED
DEMO THERE'S THE CYCLE THE CYCLE
OF DEMO.
AND DEMOCALLY BREEDING AND LIFE
TO DEMO IDEOLOGY -- SO.
DEMOLOTTESVILLE WAS REALLY KIND
OF DEMOER A IN SOME WAYS IT WAS
A A DEMORSHED MOMENT IN SOME
DEMO.
ON DEMOE WE SITE INDIVIDUALS
DEMOED ACROSS.
A DEMOIBLE LEASE TERMS ACROSS
DEMO NAVIN MILITIA AND
DEMOIVALISTS AND NEO **** AND
DEMOE SUPREMACISTS WHO
DEMOORICALLY WOULD NOT PART
DEMOTHER.
BUT DEMOR THE AUSPICES OF THIS
DEMOE BIG TEND TO VENTS UNIT
DEMOTHER I CHARLES.
DEMOLAIMING IT YOU WILL NOT
DEMOACE SIZE THE FEAR OF BEING
DEMOLANTED.
AND DEMO REFRAIN CHANGE TO USE
NOT DEMOACE ASIDE OBSESSION.
DEMO THERE'S A JEWISH PATROL
DEMO START THEIR EXISTENCE.
I'M TO DEMONITY THEY SAY.
I DEMO JEWISH CONTROL ON EVERY
ACT DEMODS OF OUR POLITICS
DEMODIATE GOVERNMENTS -- AND THE
DEMO THE AS A PUPPETEER.
WE CAN DEMO AT ANTI SEMITISM
DEMOUSE I TO FIND.
THE MAN DEMOR.
DEMOE IS A GROUP.
DEMOE BY THEIR AND SO THEY
DEMOET IMMIGRANTS.
DEMONOS AND IN PARTICULAR THE
DEMOIM COMMUNITY.
DEMOING FOR AIR HYPERBOLE.
OF DEMO IS THIS IS OUR NAY IN
DEMOR IS IN THE ANTI SH A
DEMOEST AND BURNED.
DEMO
IN A DEMO.
DEMO UP.
IN THE DEMO YEAH AND IT'S GINNY
DEMOHER ELEMENT THAT SEEM HE
DEMONEL I'LL -- OUT.
AGE ON THE DEMO GET IN THERE
DEMON ARE HATE ENVELOPES.
DEMOR BOOK SAYS.
DEMOED OF WOMEN [INAUDIBLE]
DEMO
DEMO ON LINE.
DEMO THE GAMING TO THAT WE SAY
DEMO RIGHT THE TOP IT'S A WIN
WIN -- DEMOCATING FOR ISLANDS I
DEMO YOU MENTION THE GAMING
DEMOURE CAN YOU JUST -- DIGRESS
FOR A DEMONT AND AND DESCRIBE
DEMO YOU MEAN BY THAT.
THE DEMONE CULTURE.
IS.
DEMO THE SUB CULTURE THAT EXISTS
DEMOIN THE ONLINE COMMUNITY.
HAS DEMOMOUS INFLUENCE ON THE
DEMOCH BUT ALSO IN SOME WAYS ON
THE DEMO STREAM.
AND SO WE SEE DEMOCIALLY WITH
THE DEMO CHAN.
AND DEMOT CHANNEL THESE IMAGE
DEMODS READING AND GAB AND AS
DEMO AS THE GAMING A WORLD.
ALL OF DEMOE ONLINE EFFORTS
DEMOFORMS AND VENUES IF YOU.
DEMO.
DEMOTE KIND OF DABBLE IN --
DEMOS AND IRONIC BIGOTRY -- AT
DEMOLING A JOKING ELEMENTS THAT
ALL OUR DEMOIN THIS MILIEU OF
DEMOE'S CULTURE AND IT
DEMOUENCES THEIR RHETORIC SO FOR
DEMOPLE AFTER THIS -- POWAY
DEMOCK THIS PAST WEEKEND'S
DEMOLE WENT ON AND THEY SAID --
YOU GOT A DEMO SCORE WHERE YOU
DEMOLD HAVE HAD A HIGHER SCORE
DEMOG GAMING REFERENCES TO HOW
DEMO SHOULD HAVE TARGETED -- AND
SO DEMONG SUBCULTURE IS WE SEE
IT -- DEMODING AND FEEDING INTO
DEMOGYNY AND HE TRADE -- COUPLED
DEMO SOME OF THE VIOLENT
DEMOENTS OF SOME OF THE GAMING
DEMOURE AS ITS TEACHES TO KILL
AND DEMOINATE ENEMIES AND SO
DEMOH -- YEAH.
HE I DEMOK AFTER THE ATTACK IN
NEW DEMOAND THERE WAS
DEMOERSATION AROUND ME.
AND SO CAN YOU DEMOE A LITTLE
BIT DEMOT THE RELEVANCE OF THE
DEMORTANCE OF ME.
TO DEMO AS SOON.
DEMO'S THE PURPOSE SET FOR THOSE
OF YOU NOT DEMOLIAR MEME IS
DEMOCALLY AN AND THE IMAGE --
DEMO IS -- THAT'S CREATED WITH
DEMOAGING ARE USUALLY THE USE OF
DEMOENT EVENTS -- BUT A LOT OF
THE DEMOS ARE USE AS SOCIAL
DEMOENTARY THERE USED TO PROVIDE
AND DEMOATIVE. TO POKE FUN AT
DEMOTHING NOT INHERENTLY RACIST
NOT DEMORENTLY DATED.
BUT DEMOOWING THE CHRISTCHURCH
DEMOTING FOR EXAMPLE.
DEMOROUS MEMES WERE CREATED TO
DEMOIFY THE SHOOTER MEANS WERE
DEMOTED TO TURN HIM INTO A ST
DEMORALLY.
NOT DEMO TWENTY FOUR HOURS THEY
HAD ME MS DEMO CREATED THIS
DEMOE OF BRENT IN TEHERAN AS A
DEMO. FOR A FOR HIS BRAVE
DEMOONS FOR ACCELERATING THE
DEMOCK AND BRINGING DOWN
DEMOETAL OUR SOCIETAL ISSUES.
AND AND SO DEMOS PLAY IS VERY
DEMORFUL ROLE.
DEMOALLY EXPRESSING THEIR HATE
DEMOR ENEMIES BUT USING -- HUMOR
AND DEMOY AS THEY COMMUNICATE
DEMO.
DEMOS EIGHTY L. TRACKS MEANS TO
DEMORSTAND WHO ARE THE THOUGHT
DEMOERS WHO ARE PUSHING OUT
DEMOE MEMES WHERE IS IT COMING
DEMO AND WHO ARE THE INFLUENCERS.
TO DEMOTE THAT CONVERSATION THAT
WE SEE DEMONG PLACE ONLINE.
SO -- DEMO COMMUNITY IS TARGETED
DEMON NO GROUP IS ON SKATES BY
DEMOR HATE.
AND DEMOENCE IS USED AND
DEMOENCE IS SEEN AS JUSTIFIED.
DEMOINE IF YOU FEEL THAT YOU ARE
DEMOR ATTACK.
ANY OF DEMO YOUR FUTURE IS BLEAK
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMONCE.
THE DEMO YOU KNOW I'M SURE.
AND DEMOL ACT OF AN EXAMPLE
DEMOP THAT WE IS TRACK
DEMOIFICALLY.
HI OF DEMOAGANDA FILM THAT
DEMO'RE FIRING OFF A KEY FORTY
DEMONS IS A YELL GAPS THE CHI X.
DEMO WAR NOW.
DEMOLE IN THE VIOLENCE WITH
DEMOE IS A CONSPIRACIES ABOUT
DEMOS.
WE SEE DEMOAGANDA REALLY TAKE
OFF AND I DEMO TO JUST BRIEFLY
DEMOIONED THAT.
DEMOFORNIA IS AND FOR ONE STATE
IN THE DEMOON FOR THE NUMBER OF
DEMOAGANDA ISSUED IN.
DEMOTY EIGHTEEN AND NOT IS
DEMOLETING STICKERS BANNERS
DEMOERS FLYER IS EVEN TARGETING
DEMOT HERE AT THIS UNIVERSE THIS
DEMOEGE -- MERA CAN IDENTITY
DEMOMENT PREVIOUSLY IDENTITY
DEMOPA TARGETED THIS SCHOOL WITH
DEMOR PROPAGANDA WITH THEIR
DEMOFUL -- POSTERS -- AND FLYERS
AND SO DEMOH DIVERSE CITY
DEMOROYS NATIONS IS ONE OF THEIR
DEMOAGANDA.
DEMO ALSO RECENTLY WAS TARGET
DEMO THE LAST A COUPLE WEEKS.
AND SO YOU CAN SEE THE DEMO OF
THE THE DEMOTH OF THE PROPAGANDA
AND THE DEMORS.
AND DEMO TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
DEMOTY EIGHTEEN STARTED ON
DEMOUS IS BUT WE SEE I'M HARD.
OFF DEMOUS IS FIVE HUNDRED PER
DEMO.
AND DEMON CALIFORNIA IS FOR ONE
DEMOE IN THE NATION FOR THE MOST
DEMOER OF THAT.
DEMOVE.
DEMO'S A SAMPLE THAT WE SAW AT
DEMOT THE STATE'S.
AND ALL DEMO LEE THE PLANTS SO
IT DEMOS. TO HAVE THE IDEOLOGY.
BUT DEMO YOU TRANSLATE THAT
DEMOITY TO ACTION.
AND SO DEMOENTLY ON TRIAL FOR
THE DEMOER OF BLAZE SPRINGSTEEN
IS SAM DEMOWARD ALLEGEDLY
DEMOIRED BY ADAM OFTEN.
I'D DEMOIRED AND RADICALIZED ON
DEMO MASS FOR SUNDAY CORD IS A
DEMOS EIGHT FOR AMBLE.
DEMO ACTION IN ITS CURRENT AGE.
FOR THE DEMOR PLACED STATE
DEMOBLY STABBING AT NIGHT TIME.
AND HIS DEMOIAL A GREAT IN OUR
DEMOTY.
OUR DEMO THIS VIDEO HE CHARGED
DEMO AND ARE GETTING BURNED FOR
HIS I I SAT DEMOGE GEN
DEMOUDIBLE]
AND DEMOE.
IF YOU GO DEMO THERE'S HUNDREDS
OF DEMOOS OUT IN PARTICULAR HAD
DEMOROUS VIDEOS THAT SHOW.
DEMO TO ME IS IT SHOWS -- IT'S
DEMOTER AND BROUGHT IT IS USED
BY DEMO
DEMONE HUNDREDS OF PAGES OF GAB
DEMOINGS AND EIGHTY L. ARCHIVE
AND DEMO IS ANOTHER WERE CLAD
DEMOED BY.
G..
V. S..
DEMOKS ALL OF THESE.
DEMOION. TWO BUT ALL THE WITH
THE DEMOTS.
DEMO.
DEMO HAND AND HIS AYE GALLON.
AS I DEMOED THE SYNAGOGUE YELLED
ALL DEMO MUST AYE.
WE SAW A DEMO
I DEMOD YOU PLEASE.
THE DEMOKER BECAUSE OF MY TIME
BUT I DEMOPY LET ME JUST ASK
DEMO QUICKLY.
DEMO YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH
DEMOHER CASE IT'S CURRENTLY
DEMOG I HAD A LITTLE BIT --
DEMOIDE THE PREMISES.
BUT AT LED DEMOE MOHAMMED OF THE
DEMO ON THEY DROVE FROM SEATTLE
DEMOINGTON.
ALL THE WAY DEMO TO HANCOCK PARK.
AND OR A DEMOP OF ORTHODOX JEWS
HAD DEMODENT A SYNAGOGUE HE
DEMOLA YELLED SOME IT IS MEDICAL.
DEMOR DIRECTION AND TING TO OUT
HIS ARE IN DEMOR DIRECTION YOU
DEMO BROWN.
DEMOLY MET THEM.
OF THE AND AND DEMOEVED TO BE
DEMOIRED BY -- IDEOLOGY IS S.
DEMOEMIST ISLAMIST MISS IDEA G..
AND OF DEMOSE.
DEMOMBLYMEMBER BLOOM MENTION
DEMO PASSED ON FOR TODAY THERE
DEMOPED UP.
DEMO INCREASED IS AN OFFICE.
DEMO HIS NEIGHBOR.
BUT DEMO BE SETTLED ON AND THAT
WAS TO BE OR DEMO LONG CAL YEAH.
UP ALL OF THE DEMORDING
DEMOCTMENT WAS DO.
DEMO RETALIATES AGAINST HIS
DEMOCH AND THAT WOULD PAY ON
DEMO HE WOULD GIVE HIS SUPPORT
DEMO WHERE THEY HERE. TO TAKE
HIS -- AT TO TO DEMO THEIR RANKS
I'M DEMOL LACK SADLY HATE IS
DEMOE AND WELL -- AND WITH THAT.
I DEMO TO JUST IDENTIFY OUR
DEMORT FROM LAST YEAR THAT
DEMOTIFIED 98% OF ALL THE
DEMOERS PERFECT.
OF ALL THE DEMOSTIC EXTREMIST
DEMOPS OUT THERE FOR CARRIED OUT
BY THE DEMOS OF RIGHT WING
DEMOEMISTS.
DEMOE SUPREMACISTS AND ANTI
DEMORNMENT EXTREME.
SO WE DO DEMO A SERIOUS PROBLEM
DEMO IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND DEMOE NEEDS TO BE AN EFFORT
TO DEMOS WHERE WE SEE A LOT.
OF DEMOENCE MANIFESTING AND NOT
DEMO I OFFER THAT.
DEMO THAT.
DEMOKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR I KNOW
YOU DEMO SO MUCH MORE TO TEACH
US.
WE HAD DEMO TIME -- OUR NEXT
DEMOKER -- HOWEVER IS GOING TO
BE DEMOLLY IMPRESSED -- HE IS
DEMOHALL LONG THIS YEAR.
DEMOIALIST CRIMES.
DEMOY OF LOS ANGELES.
XIN DEMOMENT RELATIONS WELCOME
DEMOK YOU FOR BEING HERE
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMOARY.
DEMOARY AUTHOR OF OUR AGENCIES
DEMOAL REPORT ON HATE CRIME.
I DEMO THAT STACK OF SIDE ON THE
DEMORATURE TABLE AT THE AT OUR
DEMOITE.
THE DEMOCY HAS COLLECTING
DEMOYZING DATA HATE CRIMES SINCE
DEMOTEEN EIGHTY MAKING IT ONE OF
THE DEMOEST STANDING EFFORTS.
OF ANY DEMORNMENTAL AGENCY TO
TRY TO DEMOY WHAT HATE CRIMES
DEMOS LIKE MY BACKYARD.
DEMO BE DRAWING FROM THE
DEMOLIGHTS FOR THOUSAND
DEMONTEEN REPORT WHICH IS THE
DEMO.
DEMONT COMPLETE A SET THAT WE
DEMO WERE CURRENT.
DEMOER AS AN EIGHTEEN THERE'S A
DEMO I PERCEPTION THAT HATE.
DEMO LET CONTROL SINCE ELECTION
DAY TWO DEMOSAND THIRTEEN
DEMOLOTTESVILLE OTHER VIA.
DEMOHENS OF NATIONALISM.
WAS RE DEMOR.
DEMO THE SONGS I THE I REPORTED
DEMO IN TWO THOUSAND SAYS
DEMONTEEN HATE CRIMES INCREASED
17% DEMOONALLY. FOR THE STUDY OF
DEMO AND EXTREMISM HAS
DEMOMENTED THAT MOST OF THE
DEMOEST AMERICAN.
SIX DEMO RECORDED INCREASES IN
DEMO CRIME.
BUT DEMO ABOUT IN A PLACE LA
DEMOTY WHERE ALL THE ONE IN.
DEMO TRUMP.
IN TWO DEMOSAND AND SEVENTEEN WE
DEMOT SHOULD. FIVE HUNDRED AND
DEMOT HATE CRIMES WHICH WITH A
5% DEMOEASE THE PREVIOUS YEAR
NOT DEMOALING OUT OF CONTROL FOR
THE DEMO
DEMO FIVE THAT INCREASES MUCH OF
DEMO BOTH STATE AND NOW -- IN
DEMO IS.
THE DEMOG TO NOTE IS.
DEMO RIGHT REPORTER ARE PART OF
AN DEMORD TREND.
DEMOES HAD AN ALL TIME LOW EIGHT
DEMOSAND AND THIRTEEN BEING UP
DEMO SINCE THEN.
AND SO DEMOG THE PAST FORTY
DEMOS.
DEMOS RIGHT 30%.
DEMOH IS CHRIST CONCERT.
DEMOHER OF LOOKING AT THE NUMBER.
OF DEMO CRIMES REPORTED IN IN
TWO DEMOSAND AND SEVENTEEN IT
WAS DEMO THAN HALF OF WHAT WAS
DEMORTED IN THAT.
IN TWO DEMOSAND AND ONE WHICH IS
ICE DEMOER EVER REPORTED BECAUSE
OF DEMO TERRIBLE AND TIMELESS
LÀ DEMO MIDDLE EASTERN
DEMOSLASH FOLLOW FOLLOWING.
DEMO ELEVEN SO ARE WE FARING
DEMO POORLY IT ALL DEPENDS ON
HOW FAR YOU DEMO BACK THE LENS
OF THE DEMORA.
DEMO CHART GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF
HOW DEMO CRIMES BREAKDOWN
DEMORDING TO MOTIVATION.
AND THE DEMOALL SHAPE WIVES ARE
DEMOETED.
DEMON'T CHANGE MUCH YOUR D..
AS IN DEMO YEAR'S HALF ACRE
DEMOOTED IT BY RACE.
WE DEMO RACIAL HATE CRIMES THE
ONE DEMOH IS OVER WHAT ONLY
DEMOESENTED VICTIMS.
CAN DEMOICANS ONLY CONSTANT
DEMOEEN EIGHT AND NINE PER CENT
OF IT DEMOTY RESIDENTS BUT CONST.
DEMO
OF DEMOH CRIME VICTIM
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMO
DEMO THAT.
WE DEMOT SEE IT PARTS OF THE
DEMOTRY.
DEMOER.
DEMO OKAY STREET GANGS PHILLY
DEMO X. AGAIN MAFIA WHICH IS THE
DEMOEST.
AND DEMO I WENT UP PRISON GANGS.
DEMO'VE GIVEN ORDERS TO THEIR
DEMOET AFFILIATES TO TRY TO
DEMOE BLACKS OUT OF THEIR
DEMOHBORHOOD SO WE SEE IN ACTS
OF DEMON IN A BROAD DAYLIGHT
DEMOTINGS.
DEMO OF THESE GUYS HAVE BEEN
DEMONG TO CARRY OUT LITERALLY
DEMOAIGNS OF ETHNIC CLEANSING.
THE DEMOND LARGEST GROUP OF HATE
DEMOE.
DEMOY YEAR THE BASED ON SEXUAL
DEMONTATION AND WE KNOW ABOUT
DEMOE CRIMES THEY OVERWHELMINGLY
DEMOET GAY MAN AS OPPOSED TO
DEMOIANS.
AND DEMO'RE MORE LIKELY TO BE OF
A DEMOENT.
DEMOER RATIO OR JUST
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMO
DEMOGION RAIMES CONST DID ONE
DEMOT FIVE AT OUR GENERAL THIRD
DEMO CAT WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT.
DEMO OVERWHELMINGLY.
THE DEMOSH COMMUNITY BUT THEY
DEMO CAN BE CRIMES IT'S PROP B.
AS AS TO THE DEMOLE.
SO DEMO ANSWER FOR OUR CRIMES OF
THE DEMO YOU'RE FEEDING.
I'M AND DEMO THE SEVEN FIRST.
IS DEMOON.
DEMOR BUT TIMES WERE OVER COMING
DEMO CRAP TARGETING I TRACK AND
DEMORE IN.
AND DEMO.
OF DEMOSE IS WHAT IS THE LARGEST
DEMOER TRANSPARENCY WE REPORTED
BUT THE DEMOTE.
DEMOE NOT FOR THAT SPEAKER
DEMONG TRANS TRANSMISSIBLE ALSO
HE DEMORA.
DEMOUSE WE ARE AT A POINT IN
DEMOORY.
DEMOE'S BEEN ON PRESIDENT OF OUR
DEMOIC EDUCATION.
DEMOURE WHICH A FOCUSED IT AT
DEMO.
I'M DEMOSIT TRANSIT IS AND SO
DEMO PAST.
I DEMO NUMBER IT TWO TO THE TWO
DEMOIOUS WOULD HAVE AVOIDED
DEMOG TO LINE FOR MEN.
DEMO POWERED FEEL THEY WILL BE A
DEMO POLICE THEY'RE NOT THE AND
DEMO ANTI TRANS GENDER CRIMES
DEMOISTENTLY THE MOST FOR THE
DEMO VIOLENT OF ALL USUALLY A
DEMO IN ANY GIVEN YEAR.
ARE OF A DEMOENT NATURE.
I DEMO WANTED TO MENTION THAT --
DEMOCAN AMERICANS WERE NOT ONLY
DEMO REPRESENTED AS VICTIMS OF
DEMOAL HATRED CRIME BUT ALSO OF
DEMOAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
DEMO CRIMES AS WELL.
DEMO WILL GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF
DEMO ARE THE CRIMINAL OFFENSES
AND THE DEMO COMMON.
DEMOE REPORTED IN TWO THOUSAND
DEMONTEEN WAS VANDALISM FOLLOWED
BY DEMOLE ASSAULTS.
DEMOAVATED ASSAULT WHICH I'M ARE
DEMOLY.
DEMODENT IMITATION [INAUDIBLE]
FOR DEMONSES [INAUDIBLE] NINE
DEMO [INAUDIBLE]
DEMO
DEMOE NO REPORTED HATE?
DEMOE FOR ATTEMPTED MURDER.
DEMO APPLE IS AT THE LAST COUPLE
OF DEMO SET IN FRONT OF A PART
DEMODING [INAUDIBLE]
DEMOR.
DEMOT TELLING HIS WAY BOB AND IN
DEMO THERE IS.
DEMO THE IN STEP ONE OF THEM IN
THE DEMO WITH A KNIFE.
AND DEMO CHECK THEM THIS IS NOT
DEMOUSE THEY WAS FORTY LEAST
DEMOTY WAS ABLE INTERVIEW.
I DO ALL DEMO AND TELL.
DR.
DEMOLLY WANTED TO SHOW YOU.
HOW HE DEMOED ON OUR STREETS?
DEMORAPHICALLY AROUND LA COUNTY --
DEMOE ARE ONLY TWO AREAS WHERE
DEMOE WERE NO CRIMES REPORTED OR
DEMO.
BUT DEMOALLY EVERY OTHER CITY
DEMOL I DID [INAUDIBLE]
I IS.
IT IS.
TO WE SEE DEMO.
DEMO'RE NOT.
DEMO LET CROP.
A DEMO COUNTY THE WE DID WAS
DEMO IT.
DEMO LET'S HAVE A MAP WITH OTHER
DEMOH.
IT TRY TO DEMOAIN WHAT MAKES MY
DEMOER NEIGHBORHOOD THE THE
DEMOER NUMBERS BAKER.
DEMOE'S IN THAT AMOUNT THIS
DEMOT.
DEMON'T YOU HOW.
DEMO PEOPLE LIVE EACH CHEN
DEMOON THEN.
A DEMOES RIP.
SO WE IS.
DEMO WHICH ADD UP TO SEE IF THE
DEMOICE PLANNING AREAS FOUR
DEMORED AND WHICH YES THE LOT
DEMOERS OF CRIMES AS WELL AS THE
DEMOEST.
DEMO THE LARGE NUMBER OF TIMES
DEMO FORTY EIGHT IN.
THE DEMOICE AREA WHICH IN THE
DEMOLE.
THE DEMOOW.
BUT DEMO JUST WEST HOLLYWOOD.
DEMOUGH.
DEMOTOWN EL BAKER TOWN.
AND IT AND DEMO RIGHTS OKAY.
DEMOOWED BY THE SAN FERNANDO
DEMOEY.
BUT IF WE DEMOARE THE POT
DEMOIONS OF THE REGION'S TO THE
DEMOR A HATE CRIMES YES THE
DEMOURE BOB GEN HAD THE HIGHEST
DEMO.
DEMO
DEMOTS LOWEST NUMBER BAKER WAS.
DEMOOT WHICH IS INTEREST BECAUSE
DEMO SOME OF THE THE GROUP ACT
UP IN DEMO WHAT'S JUST ACTIVITY.
THE DEMOR RATES OF PRIME RIB AND
DEMOIEL.
DEMOK YOU VALLEY LED BY THE
DEMOICE PLAN YEAH WE COULD SEE
IS DEMO HUNDRED AND PART SEC
DEMO AND WE'RE HERE.
AND IT GEN I DEMOK DISTRIBUTE
DEMOON WHY RATE FOR THE DISTANCE
AND DEMO ME JENNER BELOW THAT
DEMOUDIBLE]
FOR DEMO [INAUDIBLE]
AND DEMOIANS AND GAYS LATINOS --
DEMO CONSTITUTE ABOUT 8285% OF
ALL DEMO CRIME VICTIMS IN ANY
DEMON YEAR.
DEMO PART OF THE COUNTRY VERY
DEMO FEW AFRICAN AMERICANS
DEMONG THERE VERY VERY FEW
DEMONESSES WHICH CATER TO THE
DEMO COMMUNITY.
DEMO FEW SENT THE GODS OR HI.
DEMOSH SCHOOLS IN THAT REGION SO
YOU DEMO LARGELY HOMOGENOUS
DEMOHBORHOODS I LACKING A MANY
OF THE DEMOPS WHICH ARE MOST
DEMOUENTLY TARGETED.
WE THE DEMOND TO THE LAST SLIDE
HAD A DEMOH OF DOT.
DEMO LOOK LIKE THEY WOULD GO
DEMOND THE ONE TEN FREEWAY I
DEMO.
DEMOE IT'S PINK WHAT ARE THE
DEMOERENCES BETWEEN THE STARS
AND THE DEMOOR IS ARE NOT
DEMOVANT TO THIS?
DEMO THERE'S SOME.
DEMO HARD TO SEE HERE -- AT THE
AT THE DEMOE BUT THEY ON THE
DEMO AND YOU CAN PICK UP A
DEMORT ORG OR VISIT THE WEBSITE.
DEMOE ARE THE THEIR POLITICAL TO
THE DEMO MISSION.
A DEMO BE EXAM.
I'M AN L. G. B. T. DEMOES.
DEMO IS THE WEST HOLLYWOOD I
DEMOD CERTAINLY BEACH WHERE YOU
DEMOS OF BUSINESSES.
ARE DEMORED TO THE OTHER.
DEMOTY AND THE TOWN MAG IT'S
DEMOLLY FROM OUT BETTER THAN.
DEMOG TO GO.
DEMOE YOU ARE NOTICING THAT TO
ONE OF HIS OIL DEMORICT HAD?
DEMOER TAKE.
SO THE DEMOG THAT MAKES AN APT.
TO DEMO NUMBER OF HATE CRIMES
DEMO BE.
OR DEMOTY WHICH WHEN A MATT
DEMOASS GEN.
AT IN DEMO COMES IN [INAUDIBLE]
DEMOING.
IT CAN DEMO YES IT'S TOLD WITH
DEMOS OF READY.
DEMO I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL THE
DEMOEST SINCE LA -- THE 8090%
DEMOOMIC AGAIN AND THEN THEY
DEMOSFORMED RAPIDLY DURING THE
DEMOTEEN EIGHTIES BECAUSE AN AXE.
DEMO INCOME.
AND SO ON DEMOPT.
DEMOING FOR FOR A HOUSE.
DEMO HOLD THE PRESIDENT OF A
DEMOERS GAME.
DEMORTY WHERE YOU HAVE. TO
DEMOCH.
NOT DEMO ANY BETTER.
IN DEMO CASES SPEAK A LANGUAGE.
THE DEMO SPEAKER IS COMMANDER
DAY COR DEMO WAS THE COMMANDING
DEMOCER FOR LAPD'S
DEMOTERTERRORIST AND AND SPECIAL
DEMOATIONS BUREAU AND THE I
DEMONED AN INTERESTING FACTOID
DEMOT.
TO DEMOANDER KOWALSKI.
HE DEMOS EVERY MORNING AT THREE
DEMOTY AM.
I DEMOT KNOW HOW YOU DO THAT.
DEMO EVENING THANK YOU.
DEMONG ME HERE TONIGHT THIS VERY
DEMOIAL EVENT.
DEMOAINLY I DON'T MIND STAYING
UP DEMO FOR A PET LIKE THIS
DEMOGHT.
DEMOT TIME THAT I HAVE ALL THE
DEMO SAME THING OVER.
DEMORAL DIFFERENT AREAS.
IN A DEMO FROM THE PERSPECTIVE
OF DEMO LARGE.
DEMOCY BUT FROM A CITY THAT WERE
ALL DEMO.
LOS DEMOLES.
DEMO ABOUT HOW.
THE DEMONES IN INVESTIGATE
DEMOES.
N..
HOW DEMOERVILLE DOES AN AGENCY I
DEMOK OVER THE YEARS IN THE
DEMOE GETTING THESE AWOKE ITS
DEMORAL STATS?
DEMON SPECIFICALLY TO THE CITY.
AND DEMO
DEMO MORE IMPORTANTLY IS HOW WE
DEMOOND. TO NOT BE THE VICTIMS
DEMOE BUT THE PARTNERSHIP WE
DEMOLOP WITH GOVERNMENT IN
DEMOUNITY.
OUR DEMOD ORGANIZATIONS.
TO DEMO COMBAT THAT AS AN ADULT
DEMOLY -- THE PRO ACTIVE NATURE
OF OUR DEMOCE DEPARTMENT AND ALL
THE HE DEMO [INAUDIBLE] ONE
DEMOE.
DEMOH PART.
IN DEMO OF THESE CRIMES FROM
DEMOENING.
US AS DEMOE EVOLVED AS AN AGENCY
DEMO THE LAST COUPLE DECADES.
DEMOING A HATE CRIME FOR US WE
DEMO AT ANY CREEK.
A DEMOLE ACT AGAINST.
DEMO.
N. THE DEMOLE IT PULLS -- FAUPEL
DEMOD FALL UNDER THAT.
DEMO BUT A LOT TAKE I'M.
THE L. D. DEMO TRACK.
DEMO IN SECONDS.
THE DEMOK YOU FRIENDS -- IS YOU
DEMO IS.
I'M IS DEMO AGENCIES NOT A ACT
DEMODS PRETTY BASIC BUT IT'S IN.
DEMO WOULD BE OUR TRACK ALL
DEMOONS IN SO.
DEMOER ACTUALLY IDENTIFY.
DEMOTE THINK WHAT A TOP CORNER.
IS DEMOIT GIRLS TO SAVE OURS IS
IN A BOX DEMOBODY HARD ****
DEMOUDIBLE]
IS DEMODENTS -- IN NEIGHBORHOOD
AND HOW DEMO KIND OF PANIC THAT
DEMO THIRTY WE TAKE THOUGH.
I DEMO CURIOUS AS THE THE ACT.
OF DEMOING A HARP.
SO FOR THE DEMO.
BE DEMOYS TRY.
TO DEMO.
AT THE DEMOT OF IN LAW.
DEMO -- WHEN IT COMES?
IN DEMO NEXT DOWNTURN.
IS DEMO WHAT YOU IN TERMS OF
DEMOEDURES.
I DEMOK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
DEMO THAT SIZE TO ALL OF YOU IS
DEMO.
OUR OUR DEMOCE OFFICERS THAT OF
THE DEMO ALL ALL THE WAY UP
DEMOUDIBLE]
TO DEMOAEL MOORE [INAUDIBLE]
DEMO.
I AM.
DEMO IN WE QUE.
DEMOP AND ARE VERY ACTIVE THE
DEMOTE WE HEAR OF ANY.
DEMOY -- ARE THERE IS A LOT
DEMOS.
DEMO WE MAKE IT OUR PERSON WHO --
ONE DEMOGS LIKE TO CAMPUS IS.
DEMOICULT IS THAT.
DEMON THERE'S TWENTY ONE AGENT.
I DEMOK HARD ABOUT THE ENGINE
DEMO LA COUNTY DALY CITY.
WE DEMOTY ONE FROM ST STE IN THE
DEMORD TO ANY SMALL AGENCY THAT
IT.
DEMOSE BUT HE OUR STATE AND HAS
A DEMOGNATED.
WE DEMOE.
DEMOE LETTERS ANSWER BROUGH SAID.
ALL THE DEMOER.
IN DEMOE.
DEMOE AS THE INJURED
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMO YES.
DEMO WE'RE WHEN TO A? TWO IN THE
DEMO AT ALL PROVIDE PROPER
DEMORT IS.
TO ARE THE DEMOIMS AND THEIR
DEMOLIES I THINK SEASON.
DEMO THAT FOR THIS ONE AS WELL.
CAN YOU SEE DEMOER THIRTY CENTER.
DEMO THOSE.
DEMO OF THE THE NEEDS.
DEMO
DEMOET OF CAN.
IN OUR ARE DEMOING YOU WISH AND
OZ.
DEMOSGENDER GROUPS TO VERY
DEMOON IN SOME OF THE AREAS OF
LOS DEMOLES AS WELL AND IS
DEMONG.
TO DEMOTY NINETEEN WE WERE
DEMOING AT FIRST QUARTER STATS
AS DEMO AND THAT'S AN EVEN
DEMOER INCREASE OVER TWENTY
DEMOTEEN SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
DEMO.
DEMONTEEN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IT'S
DEMO CONSISTENT MY PANEL PART.
ON DEMOZE IN AND WHAT WERE CNN
AND DEMO JUST A REAL TIME NUMBER
FOR DEMO
I DEMON ANTI SEMITISM INCIDENTS
DEMOT QUARTER TWO THOUSAND
DEMOTEEN THIRTEEN INCIDENTS IN
THE DEMO OF LOS ANGELES VERSUS.
DEMO THE SAME TIME LAST YEAR SO.
DEMOAH IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
DEMOBLING TREND.
DEMO WERE WERE FOCUSED ON NOW A
LOT OF DEMOISTICS HERE WE
DEMOOUSLY CAN'T READ THIS BUT
DEMO THE LAPD WERE REALLY GOOD
AT DEMOKING NUMBERS AND WHETHER
DEMO A CRIME OUR ONE OF OUR
DEMOER CHIEF WILLIAM BRATTON
DEMOHT US HOW TO DO VERY WELL.
I WE DO DEMO JUST THE SAME WAY
DEMO WITH HATE CRIMES OF HATE
DEMOENCE.
AND DEMO THING IS A LOT A LOT OF
DEMOERENT CHARGING A BREAKS IT
DEMO.
DEMO YOU AT SEE RELIGION SEXUAL.
IN THE DEMO OF A OVAL IN OFFLINE.
SO DEMO IS A SAMPLE WE YOU THERE
DEMOLY I THINK.
WE TRY TO DEMOLE TOPS THE BULLS
DEMOT WHEN YOU GO OUT.
DEMO YOUR THAT.
OF AN DEMORTUNATE INCIDENT LIKE
DEMO [INAUDIBLE]
THE DEMOCT.
DEMO LEAVES YOU OUT THE FIRST
DEMOESSIONS THAT POLICE OFFICER
DEMONG SO WE WANT TO LEAVE A
DEMOTIVE IMPRESSION.
ON OUR DEMOIMS AS MUCH AS
DEMOIBLE IN THERE'S PAMPHLETS
DEMO WE ALWAYS PROVIDE.
I HAD TO OUR DEMOIMS IN HERE IS
A DEMOKDOWN OF OUR I MENTIONED
DEMOTY ONE POLICE MISSIONS BUT
DEMO.
THE DEMOURCE GROUPS.
I DEMOK THE SEAT.
DEMONE IS ANTI FROM A LEAGUE.
DEMO.
AND ANY DEMOHING.
DEMO USUALLY REFER TO THIS AND I
DEMO IS THE START.
IN DEMO WOULD WIN THE NINETIES
DEMO I THINK OUR TESTING
DEMOENCE PROTOCOLS CHANGED.
AND WE DEMOTED PROVIDE A RESORT
IS AN DEMO MODEL.
DEMOOW THAT IN HOW WE'RE ABLE TO
DEMO PEOPLE AS WE CAN.
AND I'D DEMO TO READ A QUICK I
DEMO THE SECOND TAX RATE -- BUT
IT DEMOD.
AYE AYE DEMO TWENTY ONE POLICE
DEMOIONS THAT.
OUR DEMOF IS MICHAEL MOORE.
EN IT DEMOR TO YOU EMPHASIZE
DEMO REVELATION BASED PIECING
THE DEMOASIS.
THE DEMONERSHIP.
DEMO OUR COMMUNITY LEADERS ARE
DEMOEHOLDERS.
ALL OF THE DEMOERENT DIVERSE
DEMOPS THAT MAKE UP LOS ANGELES.
AND DEMO INCIDENTS DO OCCUR.
DEMO IMPORTANT THAT WERE ALWAYS
DEMOHING OUT IN IN THE WHAT I
DEMOYS SAY THIS TO MY WIFE WHEN
IT DEMOS TO MY JOB.
DEMO A LOT OF HIS POLICE
DEMORTMENT.
DEMOTHING THAT HAPPENS ON THE
DEMOR SIDE OF THE GLOBE OR IN
DEMOHER STATE.
WE DEMOT DOESN'T FACT.
US DEMOCTLY AS A POLICE OFFICER
DEMOUSE WE'RE ALWAYS THINKING OF
A DEMOIFIC REGION THAT WERE
DEMOLING IN PROTECTING.
BUT DEMOE INCIDENTS IMPACT US.
DEMOE DAY WHEN WHEN THEY DO
DEMOR SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IS THE S. THE DEMOSBURGH
DEMOTING AT THE TIME I WAS A
DEMOAIN IN THE KOREATOWN AREA.
AND THE DEMOHIRE BOULEVARD
DEMOLE RABBI PUSH OR A VERY GOOD
DEMOND OF MINE THAT I DEVELOPED
A DEMOT FRIENDSHIP WED.
AND DEMO THAT INCIDENT OCCURRED
I DEMOEVE IT WAS A SATURDAY
DEMOING AND MY FIRST CALL TO HIM
DEMO
DEMOE HERE FOR YOU IS THERE
DEMOHING YOU NEED AND WE
DEMOIDED.
A DEMOCE OFFICER PRESENCE THERE
AND HE DEMO TO ME THIS.
DEMOE THAT DOESN'T.
DEMO INCIDENT IN PITTSBURGH.
I DEMOT I DON'T FEEL I DON'T.
HE DEMO THE VEGAS.
I DEMO'T FEEL LIKE IT WITH.
I WAS DEMOCTLY IN HARM'S WAY AT
DEMO MOMENT BUT THE FACT THAT
YOU OF DEMO POLICE OFFICERS
DEMOHED OUT TO ME.
DEMO THAT MADE THE BIGGEST
DEMOERENCE TO ME AND HOW I
DEMOLED IT AND I KNOW WE AND
DEMOE JUST A SMALL PART OF THIS.
BIG DEMORAM BUT THE POLICE
DEMORTMENT WHEN THINGS HAPPEN
DEMOND THE WORLD AROUND THE
DEMOON.
DEMOONDED TO THESE PARTICULAR
DEMOPS TO HELP THEM.
AND WE DEMOED ABOUT.
HOW A?
IN NEW DEMOAND AND I CAN TELL
YOU THE IS THE DEMOMIC CENTER
DEMOHERN CALIFORNIA RIGHT THE
DEMOT OF OF CREATE TOWN ON ON
DEMOTH AND OF VERMONT.
IT WAS DEMOESSIVE.
DEMO DAY ON FRIDAY AFTER THE THE
DEMODENT OCCURRED OF HOW MANY
DEMOERENT GROUPS AND LEADERS
DEMO.
OUR DEMOECTIVE ORGANIZATIONS
DEMOUGHOUT LOS ANGELES WITH
DEMOR FOR THEIR FRIDAY PRAYER
AND IT DEMO
IT WAS DEMOING TO SEE AND AND
DEMO'S JUST ONE WAY I THINK WE
DEMO
WE CAN TRY TO DEMO AND ADDRESS
DEMO BEYOND THE OUR ROLE AS LAW
DEMORCEMENT LEADERS.
DEMOLY I'LL COVER -- ARE THE THE
DEMOCTIVE EFFORTS AT THERE'S
DEMO WOMEN MENTION MY ROLE
DEMOTERTERRORISM SPECIAL
DEMOATIONS BUREAU [INAUDIBLE]
OF DEMOER RARELY KNEW FAIRLY NEW
TO THE DEMOTION BUT ONE OF THE
DEMOT -- PROJECTS I WAS ON WAS
ON MR DEMOND GO AND WITHOUT
DEMOING INTO DETAILS OF THIS
DEMOSTIGATION IT WITH THE THE
DEMORTS.
BY THE FBI IN THE LOS DEMOLES
DEMORTMENT.
THE MEN AND DEMON THAT WERE
DEMOLVED IN THIS CASE AT MANY OF
YOU DEMOH THE PRESS CONFERENCE
DEMO OCCURRED.
DEMOIER IN THE WEEK BUT IT WAS
DEMO IT SHOWED THE THE
DEMOCTIVENESS THE PARTNERSHIP.
DEMO ARE.
DEMORTMENTS HAVE TOGETHER AND
DEMOING AHEAD.
AND I DEMOEVE.
OF THE US DEMORNEY SAID AT THAT
DEMOS CONFERENCE YOU KNOW WE'RE
DEMOE NORMALLY TALKING ABOUT --
HOW DEMOY WE ARE FOR THE LOSSES
BUT DEMOY'S A DAY WHERE WE CAN
DEMO ABOUT SAVING LIVES?
AND I I DEMOK I WENT HOME AND IN
THE DEMOTY THREE YEARS THAT I'VE
DEMO A PART OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEMOCE DEPARTMENT.
AND A DEMORAN OF OUR MILITARY
DEMO WAS ONE OF THE PROUDEST
DEMO I HAD.
DEMOING THAT WE SAVED MANY LIVES
AND DEMOLIES.
DEMO IT'D BE HEARTBROKEN IN IT'S
A DEMO A BATTLE THAT WORST WERE
YOU DEMO WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DEMO ON AS A POLICE
DEMORTMENT AS ARE ALL OF OUR
DEMONERS AND WE'RE JUST I'M VERY
DEMOD TO BE IN THIS POSITION TO
DEMOFULLY HELP THIS.
DEMO ALONG AS WE WERE YOU KNOW
DEMOGATE THROUGH THIS TROUBLED
DEMO SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DEMOK.
IF I DEMO
ON ON YOU DEMO ASK YOU A
DEMOTION ON THE UNDER COVER
DEMOATIONS.
OF DEMO IS THAT -- IS THAT
DEMOTHING THAT IS -- INCREASING
IN DEMOS OF A RACE DOES THE LAPD
IS SET UP A DEMOING INTO IT AND
AS A DO YOU DEMOIDER IT -- TO AS
A DEMO OF THE ARREST OF MISTER
AGO -- IT IS DEMO -- A FERTILE
DEMOND FOR THE FUTURE IT'S A
DEMOT QUESTION SIR AS FAR AS THE
DEMOLOPMENT AND HOW MANY PEOPLE
WE DEMO.
HE I DEMOK ANY ORGANIZATION WE
DEMO TO BE.
DEMO ARE RESOURCES ARE SO
DEMOIOUS THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT
DEMO FOR OUR AGENCY AND?
DEMOO I THINK WE'VE GONE THROUGH
DEMO THE PAST FEW YEARS I
DEMOICULTY HIRING IN LAW
DEMORCEMENT -- IN AND I THINK
DEMO'S YOU KNOW STATE NATION
DEMO.
BUT DEMO WHICH AND WITH THAT
DEMOE HAD TO WORK CLOSER WITH
OUR DEMORAL.
DEMONERS IN DEVELOPING.
DEMO ASSETS AND RESOURCES THEY
DEMO IN THAT MIGHT BE.
OF THE DEMONTIMES WERE USING.
AND I'M DEMOKING A VERY GENERAL
DEMOS BUT WERE USE IN UNDER
DEMOR -- OFFICERS THAT THEY
DEMONAMED.
DEMO AREN'T.
DEMO POLICE OFFICERS BUT THEY
DEMOT BE WITH THE FBI.
OR DEMOHER FEDERAL LAW
DEMORCEMENT AGENCY.
AND I DEMOK YEARS AGO --
DEMOURALLY AS A DEPARTMENT WE
DEMO THROUGH WE USED TO JUST.
DEMO BIG BLUE WE DON'T WITH
DEMONE ELSE BECAUSE WORLD.
DEMOE BARRIERS OF HAVE OBVIOUSLY
DEMO DOWN WITH THE YEARS.
DEMO IT'S IT'S MADE US BETTER
DEMORTMENT.
DEMOD.
BUT IN DEMO CASE THANK WITHOUT
DEMOG IN TO EFFORTS ON THAT THAT.
DEMO IT'S THIS IS GONNA BE
DEMOFULLY A A ARM.
DEMO MOBILE OR WERE YOU CONTINUE
TO DEMOALUATE ASSESS OUR NEEDS
FOR DEMOR COVERS FOR THESE
DEMOICAL MOMENTS IN THESE CASES
TO DEMO LIVES.
I DEMO I AM QUESTION. ONE ANSWER
DEMO YEAH I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
NOT A LOT DEMO YOU CAN SAY --
BUT IT IT -- DEMO APPEARS TO BET
NOT DEMOARS THIS IS A VERY
DEMOESSFUL -- UNDERCOVER
DEMOATION AND BASED ON A LOT OF
THE DEMORMATION THAT -- JOANNA
WAS DEMOIDING -- THE THE OF
DEMOVITIES THAT ARE -- THAT ARE
DEMOG ON WOULD SEEM TO BE --
DEMOT FOR DRAWING OUT -- TO
DEMOVIDUALS WHO ARE PREPARING TO
BE DEMOENT AND SO IT JUST TO TO
ME DEMOS LIKE GOV FERTILE GROUND
FOR A A FOR LAW DEMORCEMENT IN A
IN IN.
ON A DEMOONAL AND I REALLY HOPE
SO DEMOUSE THE IT'S ONE OF THE
DEMO DIFFICULT JOBS I'M I
DEMOOUSLY HAVE NEVER WORKED
DEMOR COVER I MEAN YOU CAN JUST
DEMO BY THE ERICA I MEAN I
DEMODN'T.
DEMO THAT OFF AND SELL YOU MY
DEMO SAYS YOU COULD NEVER WORK
DEMOE KIND OF POSITIONS I'VE HAD
DEMO I WAS A MARINE. FOR SEVEN
DEMOS AND I CAME ON LAPD SO I
DEMOLY HAVEN'T CHANGED.
DEMOYS A TEAM BUT I GOT ENOUGH
I'M I'M DEMOL HOLDING ON TO SOME
DEMO THAT WAY TO TAKE AND I'VE
DEMO ALL THE TV SHOWS WITH THE
DEMORCOVER COPS AND IT'S ALWAYS
A DEMOUSSES.
DEMO.
I DEMOD PULL A WAITER SOMETHING
ON DEMO BUT THEY DO AMAZING WORK
I DEMO THE MEN AND WOMEN WE HAVE
DEMOR AND THEIR THEIR
DEMOLIEVABLE.
DEMOK YOU I'M OUR PHONE BILLS.
DEMO
OUR A DEMOLS.
DEMOUSE THE PUBLIC OPTION IT IS
DEMORATE AND GILBERT WHO IS THE
DEMOCIATE DIRECTOR.
OF DEMOLA MARYMOUNT UNIVERSITY
DEMOER FOR THE CITY OF LOS
DEMOLES AND WE APPRECIATE.
DEMOOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO.
AS THE DEMOMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
DEMO.
THE FOR THE DEMO OF LOS ANGELES
DEMOE WE RESURGENT.
DEMOY ANGELINA'S SO WE'D TO
DEMOIC OPINION RESEARCH WHERE WE
DEMOLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE DEMOY TO WHAT ANGELA.
DEMOKING AND FEELING.
A DEMOER OF TOPICS SEVEN UP
DEMOEYS WE IF WE'RE DOING OUR
JOB DEMOECTLY REALLY HAVE A
DEMOE ON WHAT THE PERCEPTION IS
DEMO YEAR TO YEAR.
SO DEMO IS THE MATTER.
DEMOARCH CENTER WAS STARTED AN
DEMOEMIC ONES TO WILL AND REST
DEMO HAPPENED NINETEEN NINETY
TWO OR DEMOING THE TWENTY
DEMONTH IN A THIS WEEK.
AND AS WE DEMOT HOW DO WE
DEMOARE OUR STUDENTS TO ENTER
DEMO REAL WORLD IF WE WERE DON'T
DEMO
DEMOD TO WATER THE PLANTS THAT
ARE DEMOENING.
SO YOU SAY ARE DEMOER WAS
DEMOTED OUT OF A PLACE OF TRYING
TO DEMORSTAND THE CRAZINESS AND
THE DEMOS.
AND DEMO THE HATE THAT WAS
DEMOENING IN OURS.
AND DEMORSTANDING THE STATE OF
DEMO.
NOW IS DEMOLY NO DIFFERENT.
WE DEMO TO SEE HOW DO WE MOVE
DEMOARD.
AND HOW WE DO DEMO IS THROUGH
DEMOUCTING [INAUDIBLE]
DEMOEYS.
SO DEMO WE DO WE STARTED DOING
IT DEMOY TWO YEARS AND NOW IT'S
DEMOTHING WE DO ANNUALLY WE
DEMOUCTED A SURVEY OF ANGELENOS
THE DEMO FIRST.
DEMOD ON THE BEGINNING A RIGHT.
TO DEMO.
I DEMO TO ANSWER IS AS WE CAN.
NOT TO DEMO A IN ENGLISH AND
DEMOISH AND MANDARIN AND KOREAN.
WE DEMOE. FOR TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO DEMO.
DEMOT DO THAT NUMBER SO SERVICE
DEMOER.
SO WE CAN DEMO A MARGIN OF ERROR.
DEMOIN EXCUSE ME.
DEMO IN AMERICA BUT OUR GOAL IS
THE DEMO ABLE TO TALK.
DEMO WE UNDERSTAND CAN BE LARGE.
DEMOUSE THEY OF LET'S DOES OF IN
DEMOICA AND OF AFRICAN AND
DEMONST OF WHITE ANGELENOS.
WE CAN DEMO AT RESPOND TO OUR IN
THE DEMOEY SELF FELT A WET CELL
A FOR IT DEMO ONE THING AND
DEMOLY WHAT THE PERSON TURNS ARE
DEMO THE DIFFERENT AREAS.
AND DEMO AS A QUICK SUMMARY OF
DEMOODS.
DEMOR SECTION.
IN A DEMOVE MINUTE SURVEY THAT'S
DEMO OWN EIGHT ON MINE WE ARE
DEMOERS OF THE TRANSPARENCY
DEMOIATIVE.
DEMOOUGH I DON'T SEE THAT WITH
THE DEMO WERE HAVE ANSWER
DEMOTIONS AT ANY POINT.
SO IN DEMOT.
WE DO IS THE DEMOAL GENERAL
DEMOAL SURVEY OF ANY URBAN AREA
IN THE IN DEMO THE UNITED.
SO ONE OF THE DEMOTIONS THAT
DEMOE BEEN ASKING AS A MENTION
DEMOR STARTED AS AN ACADEMIC
DEMOONSE TO THE EVENTS OF
DEMOTEEN NINETY TWO SOME OF THE
DEMOTIONS THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKING
DEMO THE YEARS.
IS HOW ARE DEMOERENT RACIAL AND
DEMOIC GROUPS GETTING ALONG SO
DEMOE ARE THE RESULTS COMBINING
DEMO THE VERY WELL AND THE
DEMOWHAT WELL RESPONDENTS.
YOU SEE DEMOT NOW IN THE LOS
DEMOLES THE REST ARE THE 3%
DEMOLENOS.
THE DEMO OF THE BASE WITH.
DEMOING A LOT.
DEMO AND THAT -- HAS I'M
DEMOAINLY IN EAST FROM ITS POINT
IN DEMOTEEN NINETY SEVEN FOR WE
ASK DEMO QUESTION.
DEMOTES AGAIN.
A DEMOHT.
DEMO THAT IS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO DEMO WANTED LOOK AT THAT BIG
DEMO BI RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS
YOU CAN SEE DEMOE'S A TEN POINT
DEMOAD WHEN WE LOOK AT WHITE
DEMO. 77% AND AT AN AMERICAN BUT
THE DEMO AT 67%.
ME ONE TO WAS DEMOT WHAT DO IN
DEMOH WILL IT ARM GET OUT.
DEMO'S A MAJOR DRIVER WHERE THE
DEMOISSION IS COMING FROM.
SO WE DEMOTED TO ASK ABOUT.
IS DEMOCE MEDIA WHERE YOU TO THE
GET THE DEMO MOST OFTEN. THIRTY
DEMO AND THEY THE FROM LOW. FIVE
BY DEMO
IT IS DEMO A MEDIA ON LEAVE
DEMOY.
OF DEMO NINE CENTS.
A DEMOD OF THEM. THIRTY ONE CAN
SAY DEMO SORT OF THING
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMOE.
DEMO THAT CAN TO IT TO SINK IN --
BUT DEMO WE DECIDED TO ASK A
DEMOTION ON OUR SURVEY EACH YEAR
SO WE DEMOD IF ANY.
ONE DAY DEMOSELVES OR A MEMBER
OF DEMOR HOUSEHOLD HAD BEEN A
DEMOIM OF A HATE CRIME IN.
TWO DEMOSAND EIGHTEEN SO 11% OF
DEMOLINOS SAY THAT THEY CAN SELL
OR DEMOONE ELSE WAS OF THEM JUST
IN DEMO DEAR. TO THE ANIMAL
DEMOR.
THE DEMOLENOS.
WE DEMO A STATISTIC EXT BELIEVE.
DEMO WOULD BE THREE HUNDRED AND
DEMOY THREE ABOUT.
DEMO.
IN DEMO COUNTY WHO OF THAT.
AND DEMO YOU HEARD IN THE
DEMOLTS FROM THERE THE
DEMOISSION ON HUMAN RIGHTS.
DEMO SEVEN HUNDRED TIMES AS
DEMOE TO BE EXACT.
SO DEMO DO WE DO WITH THIS
DEMOER IN ITS ENORMITY.
SO FOR OUR DEMOY WE KNOW THAT
DEMOEPTIONS OF HATE.
AN DEMOAL ACTS OF VIOLENCE AS
DEMOSIFIED BY THE POLICE ARE TWO
DEMOERENT. TWO VERY DIFFERENT
DEMOGS.
SO THE DEMOAL REPORTING OF HATE
DEMOES TO THE LAPD OR TO THE
DEMOIFF'S OFFICE IS MUCH GREATER
DEMO THE NUMBER OF TIMES ARE
DEMOALLY DEEMED AS HATE CRIMES.
DEMOVER WE ALL WE KNOW
DEMOCIALLY FROM READING FROM
DEMO THE COMMISSION'S REPORT
DEMO MANY MANY HATE CRIMES GO
DEMOPORTED.
DEMOVIDUALS ARE EITHER TOO
DEMOID TO SPEAK UP OR THEY
DEMOEVE NOTHING CAN BE DONE.
OUR DEMO IS SPEAKING TO THE
DEMOON SAN OF HATE CRIMES EXIST.
SO AT THE END OF THE DAY DEMOHER
DEMOE INCIDENCES WERE.
DEMOER NOT REPORTED OR THEY WILL
NOT NOT DEMOED A HATE CRIME.
THE DEMOE IS THAT INDIVIDUALS.
THE DEMO OR SOMEBODY IN THEIR
DEMOEHOLD WAS A VICTIM.
DEMO THEN WANTED TO FOLLOW UP
AND DEMOING AT DEMOGRAPHICS.
SO YOU CAN SEE DEMO 14% OF
DEMOCAN MAKE INSTALL IT BY 12%
OF DEMO.
BUT DEMO SOMEBODY ELSE WILL
DEMOCT THE HE MEANT A LOT TO
DEMO.
DEMOER.
OR AT DEMO
SO ASK DEMOT TWO DONE BY AS
DEMOE.
DEMOHELL JENNIFER LGBTQ.
DEMO ARE.
DEMO OF A HATE CRIME.
DEMO.
ONE DEMO ONLY WANT TO LOOK AT
DEMOT SO THE INTERESTING PART IS
WE DEMO THAT. EIGHTEEN A NINE
DEMO OLDS ARE SIX TIMES AS
DEMOLY TO REPORT THAT.
DEMONG IN A LITTLE.
THE DEMOL. SIXTY FIVE YEAR OLD.
WE DEMOED AT A TEN YEAR
DEMOVIDUALS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN IN
A DEMO FIVE YEARS OR LESS.
DEMO MORE LIKELY TO FAIL I'M IN
THE DEMOEHOLD THAT.
DEMOARED TO THE OPEN.
DEMO. FOUR TO FIVE YEARS OR MORE.
THE DEMOIER ICE OF THE TRUCK.
DEMOT HOW ALL IN YOU ASKED THE
DEMOOWING.
BUT IS DEMOT.
SO DEMO IS SOME OF JUST ABOUT
DEMOYS THE MOST THE TIME.
DO YOU CAN DEMO ME IS RIGHT AT
THE DEMOOM EIGHT THOSE WHO HAVE
OF DEMOE HAS BEEN.
DEMOE IS AN HONEST I'M TWENTY
ONE DEMOON GAP.
DEMOEEN THOSE TWO CATEGORY IS OF
DEMOHER NOT SAID.
DEMOE WERE OUT THERE NAY.
BUT DEMO WE STUDIED STUDIED AND
DEMORESTING TREND WE WANTED TO
DEMO AND SEE ABOUT SOCIAL CLASS
AND DEMOEPTIONS.
DEMOTIONALLY I IMAGINED THAT WE
DEMOD SEE HIGHER NUMBERS FOR
DEMOVIDUALS WHO ARE PART OF
DEMOR OR MIDDLE CLASS.
BUT WE SAW OF THE DEMOT OPPOSITE.
17% OF DEMOVIDUALS CONSIDER THEM
TO BE IN THE DEMOR CLASS.
DEMOO.
I'M BUT DEMO WERE IN THEIR HOUSE
DEMO WAS AT ANOTHER TIME.
OR DEMOENT OF MY CLASS.
WE DID DEMO THEN.
DEMOAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS AND YOU
CAN SEE IN DEMOIN EACH OF THEM
DEMO RACE.
THE PER DEMOS IT DOES LEAD TO
SIT DEMOE ARE SOME HOUSE.
SO DEMO TO DO THAT WITH ALL OF
DEMOE.
SO WE CAN DEMO REPORT ON THE
DEMOLENOS WHO AS MARSHALL SAYING
DEMO EMPOWERED OR FEEL THEY HAVE
A DEMOE TO SPEAK UP AGAINST ACTS
OF DEMO.
SO AS DEMO AS THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
DEMO EARLIER ABOUT WE CAN CHANGE
THE DEMOS SO HOPEFULLY THAT AS
DEMO AND MORE INDIVIDUALS ARE
DEMOING TO SPEAK UP.
DEMO NUMBER WILL CONTINUE TO
DEMO THOSE WHO ALREADY FEEL LIKE
DEMO HAVE A VOICE.
THE THE DEMOORICALLY AND MORE OF
A DEMOILEGED GROUP THE UPPER
DEMOS AS THEY CONTINUE TO SPEAK
OUT THE DEMOR CLASSES WILL --
DEMO SPEAK OUT AS WELL.
AND BY DEMONG HATE A NAME WERE
DEMO TO IDENTIFY IT AND THEN
DEMOY CONDEMN IT.
SO DEMO LIKE THE ONES WE ARE
DEMOUSSING HERE ARE ALLOWING
DEMOERS TO ACT.
ON DEMOLF OF THEIR CONSTITUENTS
DEMO WHEN THE UPS.
SO DEMOY EVEN WHEN THE THE LOUD
DEMOES MAY BE SAYING SOMETHING
DEMORWISE.
SO DEMO AS WE CAN'T IMAGINE
DEMOODY IN THIS ROOM WOULD THINK
DEMO A GOOD IDEA FOR A VOTER TO
GO TO THE DEMOS.
AND DEMO IN THE UNINFORMED AS
DEMO'RE MAKING THEIR DECISION WE
DEMO THAT LEADERS WOULD BE ABLE
ALL OF DEMOE -- ALL OF THESE AT
DEMOES OF DATA AS WELL.
SO IT DEMOE'S CERTAINLY NOTHING
DEMO -- NOTHING GOOD ABOUT HATE
DEMOTING IN OUR COMMUNITY BUT
DEMOFULLY WERE ABLE TO SEE THE
DEMOS CHANGE AND A TO SEE AT A
NEW DEMOGE COME ABOUT WITH ALL
OF THE DEMORTS AND ALL THE
DEMOLE HERE TODAY THANK YOU VERY
DEMO.
DEMOK YOU SO MUCH.
WE DEMO COLLECTED A FEW --
DEMOKERS CARDS -- AND MELISSA
DEMO BE HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR PARTS
IF -- IF YOU DEMON'T HAD COME IN
YET BUT LET ME -- DEMO ON OF
DEMOE FOLKS IN ORDER FIRST WE
DEMO JERRY RUBIN.
DEMO IT'S BEEN HANGING OUT BY
THE BY THE DEMOOPHONE AND WITH
DEMO UP A LITTLE.
YOU DEMO MY PERMISSION.
DEMO YOU NEEDED.
HOW DEMO THEY MISS THE COUNCIL
TWO DEMOTES?
I DEMOT HAVE A CLOCK OKAY -- I
DEMO YOU KNOW HOW TO MONITOR
DEMOSELF FEEL ON OUR WILL.
DEMOT OF ALL NATURALLY.
DEMOK YOU EVERYONE SANTA MONICA
DEMOEGE VERTICALLY YOU SEND
DEMON.
DEMOM AND ALL THE SPEAKERS THIS
IS.
DEMOABLY ONE OF THE MAIN ISSUES.
AND I DEMO IT WHEN I WAS GROWING
UP DEMOG JEWISH A LOT OF ANTI
DEMOTIC THINGS.
DEMO I WAS [INAUDIBLE]
DEMOGER.
AND THE WAY I SEE DEMO PRETTY
BAD DEMOGS.
DEMO COUPLE YEARS AT MY BUMPER
DEMOLE COMING UP USE THE N. WORD
TO DEMORIBE PRESIDENT OBAMA JUST
DEMOER OF FACTLY AND SO WE NEED
TO DEMOK OUT.
I DEMO SOME PRETTY GOOD STICKERS.
ONE DEMO NO HATERS THE OTHER
DEMO HATE IS NOT A FAMILY VALUE.
DEMOBRATE DIVERSITY UNITE
DEMONST RACISM.
DEMO'RE PRETTY POPULAR THAT'S
DEMO.
I DEMOK WE NEED TO FORM
DEMOANCES BLACK BROWN ALLIANCES
IN THE DEMOUNITY.
GET DEMOIGHT SUPPORT THE ME TOO
DEMOMENT.
DEMOENICAL COUNCILS ET CETERA ET
DEMORA.
DEMO TO SPEAK OUT HIS MINES.
NOT A DEMOPHOBIC STATEMENT ARE
DEMOST OR BIGOTED STATEMENT SO
DEMO SIT THERE AND FRANK SPEAK
OUT DEMO IF IT'S A FRIEND.
WE DEMO TO DO THAT.
WE DEMO TO SUPPORT DIVERSITY.
USE DEMOATION CONFLICT
DEMOLUTION AND ANTI BULLYING
DEMORAMS [INAUDIBLE]
AND WE DEMO SPECIALLY IN HOUSE
TO DEMOSTER TO VOTE -- ONE MORE
DEMO STICKER THAT I HAVE AT MY
DEMOE.
IT DEMO LOAN WE CAN DO SO LITTLE.
DEMOTHER WE CAN DO SO MUCH.
DEMOK YOU.
DEMO IS -- TRINITY AND MICKEY
DEMOED ROBINSON.
DEMOOME I HOPE I GOT YOUR NAME
DEMOT A YES YOU DID THANK YOU --
I DEMO WHAT I THINK YOU GUYS FOR
DEMOG HERE IT MEANS A LOT -- I
AM A DEMOENT THAT ATTENDS BRENT
DEMOS SCHOOL -- IT'S IN WEST LA
DEMO YOU MIGHT BE MORE
DEMOORTABLE IF YOU BROUGHT THE
DEMOOPHONE DOWN A LOT
DEMOUDIBLE]
GO.
DEMO HOUSE AT THIS IS PERFECT
DEMOK YOU.
DEMO COMFORTABLE -- I ATTEND
DEMOT WOODS SCHOOL IT'S ON VA
DEMO IT'S IN WEST LA -- I HAVE
DEMO A VICTIM OF COUPLE OF HATE
DEMODENTS.
AND DEMO RECENTLY -- I WAS
DEMOED ON A HATE LIST BY A
DEMOER BRENT WOODS STUDENT WHO
IS IN THE DEMOOMORE CLASS.
AND SHE DEMO SHE LEFT BROWN WITH --
TO GO TO DEMOS FRANCE LAST YEAR.
AND SHE PUT ME ON DEMO HATE
DEMOED -- IN MARCH.
AND DEMO ANOTHER GIRL WHO
DEMOENTLY ATTENDS BRENT WOODS
DEMO AND THE CLASS OF THE
DEMOOMORE CLASS.
AND DEMONTLY ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO
SHE DEMONDS MY CHAIR PRACTICE.
AND SHE DEMOIONS THAT SHE HAS A
WAY OUT TO DEMOS.
AND TO END AND THE DEMO TWO DAYS.
AND SO.
IT WAS BY FAR THE DEMO IS --
DEMO THING I'VE EVER EXPERIENCED
TO DEMO THAT SOMEONE I NEVER MET
DEMORE NEVER SEEN BEFORE IN MY
DEMO.
DEMOS AT MY CHAIR PRACTICE JUST
DEMOY TO START DOING WHATEVER
DEMOS THERE TO DO.
AND DEMO TOLD FACULTY AND STAFF
DEMOING HAS BEEN DONE ABOUT IT --
DEMOE.
DEMO DON'T WANT TO DO ANYTHING
DEMO'RE NOT TRYING TO ROCK THE
DEMO THEY WANT TO STAY BEHIND
THE DEMOES WHICH I TOTALLY
DEMORSTAND.
BUT DEMOING IS GOING TO BE DONE
DEMOSS WE SPEAK UP.
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU FOR FOR
DEMONG A SENATOR LIMIT JUST
DEMOA SAY I'M REALLY PROUD OF MY
DEMOHTER BECAUSE I KNOW IT TAKES
DEMOAORDINARY COURAGE FOR A
DEMOEEN YEAR OLD REALLY TACK. TO
DEMOKER TRUTH I'M.
I AM AS A MOM AT DEMOTWOOD
DEMOOL.
AND IS OUR DEMOND YEAR HERE THIS
IS MY DEMOHTER FAITH ISABELLA.
AND DEMO.
DEMOS START HERE.
OUR DEMOOL HAS BROUGHT IN EIGHTY
DEMO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEMOASTRUCTURE PROJECT.
DEMO ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DEMOARS WHICH IS A TENTH OF A
DEMOION DOLLARS.
ON AND DEMO STRIKES ME AS ODD.
IN OUR DEMOUNITY IS THAT.
DEMOE GOT AMAZING TEAM AMAZING
DEMOF AND IT'S AMAZING ABILITY.
TO DEMORAGE A HUNDRED MILLION
DEMOARS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
DEMOECT BUT OVER THE PAST
DEMORAL MONTHS WE'VE HAD.
DEMOICIT F. ****.
IN OUR DEMOROOMS. THREE TIMES
DEMOADY.
AND MY DEMOHTER SHE'S RECEIVED
TAX DEMOAGES REFERENCING THE KU
DEMO KLAN REFERENCE RATES
DEMORENCING.
DEMO MOVEMENT GOING ON ON THE
DEMOUS AND WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
DEMOORT FROM A LOT OF CARING
DEMOTS.
BUT DEMOY THE QUESTION THAT I
DEMO FOR YOU IS YOU KNOW I'M A
DEMOLE MOM HOW HOW DO I PROTECT
MY DEMOS.
WE GOT A LOT OF DEMOING PEOPLE
IN THE DEMO HERE.
BUT I DEMOL DON'T HAVE ANY
DEMOERS WE'VE MADE A POLICE
DEMORT.
YOU DEMO LAPD THEY'RE GOING TO
GO DEMOD AND PURSUE CHARGES
DEMONST THE GIRLS -- WHO MADE
DEMOE VERY HATEFUL?
DEMOENTS AND THREATS TOWARDS MY
DEMOHTER BUT WE'RE STILL NOT
DEMO SHE CALLED ME SHE SAYS MOM
THE DEMO FROM FRANCE'S ON CAMPUS.
DEMOCE THE UK I DON'T KNOW
DEMO'S GOING ON HERE BUT IF WE
DEMO THE ABILITY AND I LOVE MY
DEMOOL THE REASON WHY WE'RE
DEMOE IS BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
THE DEMO VALUES THAT WE STAND.
FOR BUT IF WE CAN DEMOE A TENTH
OF A DEMOION DOLLARS.
BUT WE DEMOT STOP THE HATE
DEMOES THAT ARE OCCURRING ON
DEMOUS I HAVE A SERIOUS QUESTION.
FOR DEMO AND SO I'M AN ADVOCATE
DEMO I'VE WORKS FOR THE
DEMORNMENT VETERAN I WORKED I
WAS ON THE DEMONCE DEEPER
DEMOENT OBAMA I'VE YOU KNOW I'VE
GOT A LOT OF DEMORNMENT
DEMOLADES.
I DEMOT HAVE THE ANSWERS SO I'M
DEMO TONIGHT BECAUSE I WANT
DEMOND THAT PUBLIC PRIVATE
DEMONERSHIP. FOR YOU TO WORK
DEMO US WORK WITH BRENT WOULD
DEMO WITH ME.
DEMOS FIGURE SOMETHING OUT
DEMOTHER AND LET'S KEEP OUR OUR
DEMO SAFE BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
A DEMOLEM FOR BLACK PEOPLE.
DEMOE'S A PROBLEM FOR OUR
DEMOUNITY.
YOU DEMO AND THIS IS IT'S
DEMONITELY CAN TURN THE
DEMOTHING THAT COULD BE A
DEMOONAL SECURITY.
DEMOATION SO I'M JUST I'M VERY
DEMOEFUL TO BE HERE I'M GLAD
DEMO.
TED LIU DEMO HIS OFFICE EXTENDED
THE DEMOTATION AND I REALLY
DEMOECIATE YOU I JUST HOPE YOU
DEMOINUE THIS DIALOGUE.
DEMOK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU.
I DEMO -- JOANNA HAS A HAS A
DEMOENT BUT I I WANT -- TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR DEMOG HERE --
DEMOICULIER CUTE LITTLE ON BUT
OF I DEMOKLY I DON'T THINK WE
DEMO THE ANSWERS -- BUT WE'RE
DEMO TO NIGHT IN AN EFFORT -- TO
TO DEMO YOU IN FINDING THE THE
DEMOERS.
AND THE ONE OF THE DEMOONS THAT
I DEMONED TONIGHT ONE OF THE
DEMOGS THAT I WANTED TO
DEMOLIGHT LATER BUT ALL ALL SET
NOW IS -- I DEMO REPEATING -- OF
DEMO BRAND SAID IS THAT ONE OF
THE DEMORTANT THINGS THAT WE
DEMO TO DO IS TO EMPOWER AND AN
OLD AND DEMOLE TO SPEAK UP.
AND DEMO'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU'VE
DEMO SO I THINK THAT'S A VERY
DEMORTANT STEP IN AND OF ITSELF
HI DEMONA -- AND THIS IS THE
DEMOER.
DEMO I ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU --
FOR DEMONG HERE AND SHARING YOUR
DEMOH.
AND DEMOKING TRUTH TO POWER
DEMOE IS A PROGRAM AND THIS IS
NOT A DEMOTION BUT OF A JUDGE
DEMOE WEST OPERATES A PROGRAM
DEMOED SHADE I HAVE ATTENDED
DEMO OF THEM AND THEY'VE
DEMOALLY BEEN AT THE MUSEUM OF
DEMORANCE.
DEMOE?
DEMO ABOUT HATE CRIMES -- THAT
DEMOG PEOPLE.
ARE -- DEMOG AN EIGHT HE'S A
DEMOE IN SO THEY HAVE TRIALS
DEMO YOUNG PEOPLE -- AND THEY
DEMOLY TALK ABOUT.
DEMO HATE CRIMES ARE WHY YOUNG
DEMOLE ARE DOING THEM AND AND
DEMOE FOLKS THAT DO THE AXE
DEMOALLY HAVE TO STAND TRIAL A A
A IN IN DEMOT OF THEIR PEERS? TO
BE DEMOED AND TO BE PROSECUTED
BY DEMO AND IT'S A WAY TO KIND
OF DEMOENT THOSE THINGS FROM
DEMOENING -- BUT IT'S ALSO AN
DEMORTUNITY TO KIND OF RAISE
DEMOENESS ABOUT WHAT HATE CRIMES
ARE IN SO I DEMOD CERTAINLY HOPE
AND DEMOE THIS IS SOMETHING.
DEMO STAFF CAN HELP FACILITATE
BUT TO DEMO THAT SCHOOL -- REACH
OUT TO OR TO DEMO THE SHADES
DEMORAM REACH OUT BECAUSE IT
DEMODS LIKE -- THERE'S SOMETHING
DEMOLING -- AT THIS SCHOOL THAT
DEMOLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND
I DEMOK WHAT THEY SAY --
DEMOIGHT IS THE BEST
DEMONFECTANT SO I WOULD
DEMOAINLY RECOMMEND -- WORKING
DEMO THE SHADES PROGRAM --
DEMOUSE THAT SPECIFIC TO HATE
DEMOES -- DONE BY YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND DEMO TO ADD AS WELL SHADES
IS A DEMOOMENAL PROGRAM EDL
DEMOALLY HONORED IN A PROGRAM
DEMO -- EIGHTY ARIAL SHE'S --
DEMOES AND AND THE JUDGE -- WE
DEMO HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED A
DEMOD OF DIFFERENCE THAT COMES
DEMO THE SCHOOLS AND WORKS ON
DEMOATION AND ANTI BIAS.
AND THE DEMOEPT IS THAT IF HE
CAN BE DEMONED.
HE CAN BE DEMOARNED BUT WHAT
DEMOENS IS WE START WITH THIS
DEMOMID OF HATE AND AT THE VERY
DEMOOM.
IS THE DEMOET THE CYBER BULLING
THE DEMOUAGE THE RHETORIC THE
DEMOS BUT AT THE TOP OF THE
DEMOMID.
IS DEMOCIDE WRITES IN THE MOST
DEMOEME SENSE AND WHAT WE NEED
TO DO AS A DEMOUNITY.
IS TO DEMOESS THINGS AT THAT
DEMOOM OF THE PYRAMID LEVEL AT
THE DEMOOM THAT TRIANGLE. TO
DEMO WITH LANGUAGE TO DEAL WITH --
THE DEMOR CYBER HATE -- AND TO
DEMOESS THAT AT AN EARLY STAGE
I'M SO IF IF WE CAN DEMO I
DEMOURAGE YOU TO GET TO THE
DEMOTY L. TO A WORLD OF
DEMOERENCE PROGRAM.
DEMOK YOU AGAIN -- I JUST WANT
TO SAY ONE DEMO THING -- I JUST
I DEMOLY FEEL LIKE -- WAITING TO
DEMOESS THESE CONCERNS IT'S ONLY
DEMOA PUT.
OUR DEMOTY AND OUR COUNTRY MORE
AT DEMO SO I THINK THAT THE
DEMOER WE WAIT TO ADDRESS THESE
DEMOES IT'S GOING. TO TURN INTO
A DEMOER SITUATION AND SO I A
DEMONGLY SUGGESTS THAT -- THAT
YOU DEMO FIND A WAY TO ADDRESS
DEMOE CONCERNS SO.
ON THE DEMO GENERATION LIKE ME
HE DEMO NOT HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
DEMOTY AT SCHOOL BECAUSE I JUST
DEMO THAT'S A REALLY BIG CONCERN
DEMO WE SHOULD ALL BE CONCERNED
DEMOT.
DEMOK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
DEMO FOR US TO DO THAT.
DEMO'S WE HAVE TWELVE PHYLLIS
DEMOER.
AND DEMO -- BOB CALLAHAN
DEMOUDIBLE]
DEMOK YOU.
ALL FOR DEMOG HERE AND I REALLY
DEMOECIATE THIS FORM.
AND IT IS DEMO TRUE ABOUT.
DEMO CRIMES IN SANTA MONICA SO
IS DEMOLY NO SHOCK.
DEMO IS REALLY IS DISTURBING IS
DEMO THERE IS A SEGMENT OF OUR
DEMOETY?
DEMO HAVE FOUGHT FOR THIS
DEMOTRY.
AND DEMO EXPECTED THE FREEDOM TO
BE DEMOYED BY ALL WE KNOW
DEMOACLES AND HATE. TO INTERFERE
DEMO.
I'M DEMOICULARLY ONE I HAVE.
DEMO VETERANS ARE COMING IN MORE
DEMOESSED NOT BY PTSD FROM THEIR
WAR DEMOLES BUT BY THE WAR
DEMOLES BEING HOME.
DEMOE THEIR COUNTRY IN TO BE
DEMOESPECTED.
I I RUN A DEMOAPEUTIC ARTS
DEMOION.
AND NOW IS DEMOME.
IT IS DEMOE ISM IN ORDER TO RE
DEMOGIZE THEMSELVES TO FIND OUT
DEMO CAN WE DO AND WHAT CAN HOW
WE CAN DEMOCT THE NEXT ELECTION.
SO WE CAN DEMO WAY A PERSON WHO
DEMOTED THIS SURGE OF HATE.
SO AND I'M DEMO YOU ALL KNOW
DEMOT BONE SPURS.
SO.
I'M I'M DEMO I'M FEELS MILLER
DEMOED IN THE NAVY AND I'M
DEMOND SEVERAL VETERANS.
WHO ARE DEMOCTED BY THE STRESS
OF DEMOTRIES WERE WE GOING TO
DEMOLE?
WE DEMOT SEE COLOR.
WE DEMOECT EACH OTHER IS LIKE A
DEMOLY OF ONE FROM VARIOUS.
OF DEMONE MARINE UP THERE.
AIR DEMOE NAVY COAST GUARD AND
SO DEMOH SO I JUST WANT TO SAY.
DEMO IS TAKING THEM SO LONG TO
DEMORCE THE IMPEACHMENT PROCESS?
THE DEMOLE OFF TOPIC.
BUT IT IS A DEMOP OF ONE SOURCE.
DEMOK YOU.
THE DEMORSTAND YOUR INTEREST --
BOB DEMOAHAN.
AND DEMO DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER --
DEMO.
BOB DEMOAHAN.
I DEMO THE A NAM VET MARINE
DEMOAIN SIR LONG BEFORE COUNTRY.
AND DEMO A REAL IT'S IN A QUORUM
MY DEMOHER FROM ANOTHER MOTHER.
WE SEE DEMOR.
DEMO GREEN.
DEMO WAS IT.
DEMOE WAS NO RACISM MORE.
DEMOUSE WE ONLY GET ALMOST
DEMOHES ON THE BACK.
DEMOK GOD I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE
DEMO A LOS BROTHERS LONG OVERDUE
DEMOO THIS.
ME DEMOY.
BUT FOR DEMO [INAUDIBLE]
NO. FOR DEMO NOW AND I CAN SEE
DEMO TO THE WHOLE PANEL.
DEMO A STEEP HILLS AND CAUGHT IN
NEW DEMOUDED.
DEMOUSE WE ALL COME FROM THE
DEMO FOR A ROOM MUSLIM NATION
DEMOT.
THE DEMONATION RELIGION ANYTHING.
WE ALL DEMO FROM ONE FOR APRIL.
DEMO THE BIBLE TORAH KORAN
DEMOES.
DEMOL [INAUDIBLE]
TWO ONE DEMORAL [INAUDIBLE]
HIS DEMO.
AND DEMOO.
THE DEMOER MADE.
DEMO'S RICH DESTINATION COME
DEMO THIS IS US.
DEMO WE BECOME.
DEMO WILL BECOME LARA?
IS NOT DEMOTHING WE'RE BORN.
DEMO TAUGHT.
DEMOCT THE AB.
MY DEMOE WHO LIVE TODAY MINISTER
DEMOSE GOD THE LOVE FOR HIM.
HE WAS A DEMOER THE RED BALL
DEMOESS THE HELP LIBERATE THE
DEMOING HERE.
AND DEMOCTIVELY IN GERMANY.
DEMOON'S WOODS AND DOT COM.
SEE ALL I DEMO MY HISTORY.
I DEMO MY FAMILY PROBLEMS WILL
BE DEMO.
ALL DEMOE WHO SERVE MY DELTA SIR
AYE DEMO
IN ALL DEMOSION CLOSING SO
DEMOER LIKE RESEARCH.
ALL DEMO WE CAN BRING SLOW IT'S
NOT TOO DEMO.
WE ALL DEMOP WITH HE LEAVE THE
DEMO ONE SUSPICION THE HILL.
YOU CAN DEMO CAR ONCE BUSINESS
DEMO'S OWN VERSION WE MAY KILL
DEMO WHICH IS.
DEMO THIS FULLY THE HOPES AND
DEMOMS AS FAR.
DEMOO CHOOSE ONLY CREATION THE
DEMOHER SOULS OWN SALVATION.
ALL DEMO REQUIRED IS IMAGINATION.
DEMOCALLY LEARN A LOVE.
DEMO.
DEMOK YOU VERY MUCH.
DEMOK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
DEMOHING AND BEAUTIFUL WORDS AND
DEMOK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
I DEMOT THINK OF BETTER WORDS TO
AND ON HOW HOW DEMOOPRIATE -- A
NO ONE DEMO
IS DEMO WITH HATE.
DEMOWHERE ALONG THE LINE -- AS
ONE DEMOS -- IT GETS ABSORBED --
IT DEMOMES CREATED AND THEN
DEMOS INTO BEHAVIOR.
OF I DEMONED A FEW THINGS DURING
THE THE THE DEMOSES -- TODAY'S
DEMOING ONE IS -- THAT I NEED TO
DEMON A LOT MORE ABOUT GAMING
DEMOURE YOU KNOW IN THE
DEMOTICAL WORLD -- WE SPEND A
LOT OF DEMO FOCUSED ON SOCIAL
DEMOA.
ON DEMOBOOK AND TWITTER AND A
LOT OF THE DEMOVIOR THAT WE SEE
DEMOE AND YOU SEE -- IN FACT
DEMOY FACEBOOK THROUGH SOME
DEMOLE OFF OF OF A FACEBOOK --
DEMO -- FINALLY -- AND YET --
DEMOENING TO CHILL OUT OF
DEMOE'S THAT WHOLE CULTURE
DEMOND GAMING IN THE SUB CULTURE
AND FOR DEMOT CHAN -- THAT VERY
FEW OF US DEMO ANYTHING ABOUT OF
MY DEMOT -- AND YET -- THIS IS A
DEMODING GROUND FOR HATE SO --
WE DEMO TO GET A HANDLE ON THAT
AND DEMORSTAND IT BETTER AND I
DEMO -- THE LAPD IS IS DOING
DEMO THAT I AND I I THINK --
DEMO FOR OTHER PANELISTS MAYBE
DEMOE'S MORE RESEARCH AND MORE
ON DEMORING THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
DEMOE -- THIS IS THE HOME. TO
DEMOFORNIA'S HOME TOO MUCH OF
DEMO SOCIAL MEDIA SO WE HAVE A
DEMOIAL RESPONSIBILITY I THINK --
TO DEMOOUT NEGATIVE BEHAVIOR --
HOW DEMO I SAID BEFORE --
DEMOWERING AND BUILDING AND
DEMODING PEOPLE TO SPEAK UP --
IS DEMORLY -- A SOMETHING THAT'S
DEMORTANT -- IT'S A A KEY TO
DEMONNING TO ADDRESS THE HATEFUL
DEMOVIOR THAT WE SEE AROUND US
AND DEMONG HEARINGS LIKE THIS
AND THE DEMOS OF PROGRAMS.
DEMO ALL OF YOUR ORGANIZATIONS --
TO DEMO
DEMOFUL AND THAT GIVING HATED
DEMO THE SAME THING BRING OUT OF
DEMO WAS -- THAT WAS YOUR QUOTE
DEMOT SORRY -- THAT THAT KIND OF
DEMONATES WITH ME WE HAVE TO BE
DEMO TO DEFINE AND UNDERSTAND --
DEMO HATE IS IN ORDER TO TRULY
DEMOESS IT?
AND AND TO AND DEMO I'VE I'VE
DEMOD YOU SAY THIS BEFORE -- IF
HE CAN BE DEMONED THAT HATE CAN
BE DEMOARNED AND THAT'S PROBABLY
THE DEMO HOPEFUL THING AN
DEMOMISTIC GOD -- THING -- THAT
DEMO WE CAN LATCH ONTO BECAUSE
IT -- IT DEMO GIVE US THAT
DEMOMISM THAT WE ACTUALLY CAN DO
DEMOTHING ABOUT THIS IT'S GONNA
DEMO TIME IT'S GONNA TAKE EFFORT
DEMO GONNA TAKE UNDERSTANDING --
AND A DEMO OF A LOT OF WORK BUT
I'M DEMO YOU'RE ALL HERE -- AND
DEMOING TO ENGAGE IN THAT
DEMOUSSION.
DEMOEY DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
DEMOENTS THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
DEMO I'M SURE YOU DO.
DEMO IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I
DEMO -- THE VERY SHORT BUT THIS
WAS DEMOEDIBLE.
AND DEMO THE LIGHTS GO OUT THIS
IS DEMO YOU KNOW IT'S TIME TO GO.
DEMOSS THE DISCO BALL COMES OUT.
DEMO I'M OKAY -- YOU KNOW
DEMOGHTENING DISTURBING
DEMORMATION -- I YOU KNOW I SAID
ON DEMOIC SAFETY AND WE TALK SO
DEMO WE SEE SO MANY BILLS THAT
ARE DEMOLY TALKING ABOUT YOU
DEMO HOW WE CAN ADD MORE.
DEMOL CODES -- TO OUR SYSTEM AND
DEMOECUTE BUT IT'S IT'S NOT SO
DEMO ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE KNOW
DEMO IT'S REALLY -- HARD TO
DEMOALLY PROSECUTING CRIME.
BUT HOW DO WE PUT DEMO MONEY AND
DEMO FOCUSED AND MORE ENERGY
DEMO THE WORK THAT YOU ALL ARE
DEMOING -- AND HOW DO WE FIGURE
OUT DEMO TO BUILD TRUST BETWEEN --
DEMORALLY DISENFRANCHISED
DEMOALLY DISENFRANCHISED
DEMOUNITIES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
SO DEMO WE HAVE FOLKS WORKING
DEMOTHER TO COME BACK.
DEMOES IN INCIDENTS THAT ARE
DEMOENING THAT PROBABLY ARE
DEMOR REPORTED IF REPORTED AT
ALL DEMOUSE THE FOLKS THAT ARE
DEMOALLY YOU KNOW UNDER DURESS.
ARE DEMOL WORKING TO REBUILD
DEMOR RELATIONSHIPS WITH LAW
DEMORCEMENT AND AND AND FROM THE
DAY DEMO IT SHOWS THAT THOSE
DEMOPS ARE IN NEED OF THE MOST
DEMOECTION.
AND SO HOW DO WE DEMOALLY WORK --
IN THE DEMOSLATURE TO TO PAVE
THE WAY FOR DEMOE -- THAT KIND
OF DEMORESS TO HAPPEN.
AND THE DEMONG CULTURE AS WELL I
DEMO I WAS THINKING WE HAVE
DEMOOUS WORK TO DO IN THAT AREA
WE DEMO OF FOCUS ON HOW TO
DEMOLATE THEM FOR REVENUES SAKE.
BUT DEMOLY LOOKING AT THE
DEMORCURRENT OF HATE COMING FROM
DEMO CULTURE -- IS IN LIGHTNING --
I DEMO TO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
DEMOWING ME TO BE PART OF THIS
DEMOITTEE AND I HOPE EVERYONE
DEMOS THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
DEMO WE WILL BE FOCUSED ON FOR A
DEMO LONG TIME -- BECAUSE IT IS
DEMORTANT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
DEMO HATE AND NAME IT IS
DEMORTANT TO CALL IT OUT IS IT
IT IS DEMORTANT TO CHECK OUR OWN
DEMOES -- AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO
DEMO TOGETHER -- TO FIGURE OUT
DEMO TO REDUCE IF NOT ELIMINATE --
THE DEMOUDICES THAT ARE DRIVING --
AND THE DEMO THAT IS DRIVING --
DEMOE KINDS OF INCIDENTS.
DEMOK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COM
LOG GOV -- DEMOK YOU TO OUR
DEMOLISTS ONCE AGAIN JOANNA
DEMOHALL DAVID BRAND PLEASE.
DEMO THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE --
AND DEMO AGAIN I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE DEMOLE WHO HELPED PUT
DEMO PROGRAM TOGETHER --
DEMOICULARLY MY STAFF MY GREAT
DEMOF WAS HERE MELISSA KOFFLER
DEMO EVERYBODY'S HERE GUYS DRAW
DEMO KIRBY'S CAM PERSHING A
DEMONT CAR WERE.
AND DEMORT LOZANO THANK YOU ONE
AT ALL